Danke für's Zuschauen! Ein bisschen zielen. Nach 10, am letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Das bedeutet Zeit fürs Chaos Radio. Jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat hier auf Fritz übernimmt der Chaos Computer Club nämlich den gesamten Äther, bringt ein Thema mit und informiert euch darüber, erklärt euch darüber und lässt euch auch dazu Fragen stellen. Und normalerweise, wenn die Leute hier sind, ist es so, dass viele Leute, die nichts mit diesem ganzen Computerkram zu tun haben, denken so What, über was redet ihr da gerade? Heute ist das anders, denn das Thema, um das es heute geht, das habt ihr alle auf jeden Fall in den letzten Wochen schon mal gehört, wenn ihr nicht total hinter dem Mond gelebt habt oder unter einem Stein. Das ist nämlich der sogenannte Staatstrojaner, um den soll es heute gehen. Diese Software, die es den staatlichen Behörden erlaubt, euch zu überwachen und euch, möglicherweise, aber nur, wenn böse Beamte was damit zu tun haben, auch was unterzuschieben. Aber warum das so ist und was das genau bedeutet, das klären wir heute im Verlauf der Sendung. Zu der ich herzlich begrüße, Constanze Kurz, vom Chaos Computer Club, hallo und guten Abend. Und Nibla vom Chaos Computer Club, hallo und guten Abend. Jetzt gibt es möglicherweise auch schon Leute, die sagen, um Gottes Willen, Staatstrojaner, das haben wir die ganze Zeit schon gehört. Aber es gibt ja Neuigkeiten. Es gibt ja gerade jetzt auf CCC, die ganz oben steht, es gibt einen neuen Staatstrojaner. Was genau heißt neuer Staatstrojaner?
Naja, die Version, die wir ursprünglich, als wir am 8. Oktober damit raus kamen, analysiert hatten, die ist jetzt ja schon ein paar Monate alt gewesen, also eigentlich ein paar Jahre kann man sagen. Und jetzt haben wir uns ein bisschen neuerer Versionen zugewandt. Die ist nämlich vom Dezember 2010 und sehe da die vielen Behauptungen, die wir nach unserer ersten Veröffentlichung dort hatten, nämlich, dass das ja eher so eine veraltete Version ist und dass all die Fehler, die wir da gefunden haben und doch überhaupt die Fragen der Rechtswidrigkeit von bestimmten Funktionen, die seien alle behoben in neueren Versionen.
Das muss man mal anmerken, also die eigentliche Kritik, die da kam, war irgendwie nicht ebenheitlicher Natur, sondern da wurde dann gesagt, ja das ist irgendwie ganz alte Software, das haben wir in der Zwischenzeit schon alles behoben und die neueren Versionen, die haben das alle nicht mehr. Und da ist das alles ordentlich und dann muss man halt schon nochmal nachlegen und sagen, hier, Version aus dem Zimmer letzten Jahres, immer noch kaputt.
Also man muss es, also ein Vergleich glaube ich, ein Bildervergleich wäre, ein Getränkehersteller bekommt eine Anklage, weil in sich in seinen Getränken Glasscherben befinden. Und er sagt dann so, das ist aber seit zwei Jahren gar nicht mehr so, deswegen ist es kein Verbrechen.
Und dann guckt man sich eine neue Flasche an und stellt fest, oh, Scherben drin.
Es gibt bei diesem ganzen Thema Staatstrojaner viele Punkte, wo ich fragen möchte, woher wisst ihr das eigentlich? Und das ist schon der erste zu sagen, woher wisst ihr denn, dass ein Staatstrojaner, den ihr auf seltsamen Weg, auch darüber müssen wir noch reden, bekommen habt, vom Ende des letzten Jahres ist. Sind da Stempel drauf?
Nein, es sind da keine direkten Stempel drauf. Wir können auch, was die Herkunft dieses Trojaners betrifft, nicht so ganz vorständige Angaben machen, denn wir müssen natürlich, genau wie in dem ersten Fall, den wir veröffentlicht haben, unsere Informanten schützen. In dem ersten Fall war es ja so, dass quasi der Betroffene, also der Strafverteidiger des Betroffenen selbst, an die Öffentlichkeit ging und dann sagte so, also ich habe diese Festplatte dem CCC gegeben. Hier ist es bisher nicht so und wir müssen uns da ein bisschen bedeckt halten. Aber schon, weil die beiden Trojaner ausgesprochen ähnlich sind, jetzt vom reinen Aufbau, aber auch von den Funktionitäten, die wir gefunden haben und letztlich auch von dem Verschlüsselungs-Key, der da drin ist, können wir schon davon ausgehen, dass wir wieder einen Staatstrojaner mit einiger Sicherheit untersucht haben und wird ja auch nicht wirklich bestatten.
Aber woher wisst ihr, dass der sozusagen eine aktuelle Reversion ist als der andere?
Aus Gründen. Naja, es kann natürlich noch sein...
Wohl halt zu einer späteren Zeit eingereicht und unterscheidet sich schon ein klein wenig, aber man sieht halt deutlich, hat sich stets bemüht, aber...
Naja, wir haben natürlich zu anderen noch die Versionsnummer, die ja deutlich aufgestiegen ist, das kommt noch dazu.
Also die kann man auch schon drin finden?
Mhm, 3644 ist es jetzt, also nur 3644. Und da sind natürlich schon einige Sprünge dazwischen.
Was war die erste?
Die erste, die wir hatten, war eine 3-4-Punkt-irgendwas. Also da sind schon einige Zeit dazwischen.
Wird es dann für die 4er-Version eine Werbeanzeige geben?
Bin ich sicher, irgendwie, weil die Herstellerfirma, die ja digital ist, heißt, da noch großartige Werbung macht, keine Ahnung.
Das wollen wir noch mal sehen. Es gibt jetzt also diese neue Version des Trojaners. Eine wichtige Sache, muss ich gleich noch mal anfangs noch klären. Es ist ja euch ja ganz wichtig, dass es Staatstrojaner heißt und nicht Bundestrojaner. Warum?
Naja, der Begriff Bundestrojaner ist eigentlich in gewisser Weise schon besetzt. Denn immer, wenn man früher in der ganzen Debatte über die Online-Dücksuchung gesprochen hat, wie sie ja damals auch in Karlsruhe verhandelt wurde, da war eigentlich der Bundestrojaner so ein bisschen ein Synonym. Und wir haben jetzt aber natürlich, weil wir auch von Anfang an wussten, dass die Software, die wir zuerst untersucht haben, eher ein Landestrojaner ist. Also schon von Behördentrojaner letztlich, aber eben nicht zu einem BKA gehört oder zu einer jeweils Bundespolizei, sondern eben zu einer Landespolizei. Und deshalb wollten wir das auch begrifflich gerne auseinanderhalten.
Aber letztlich haben wir den Landestrojaner, den Regionaltrojaner, was auch immer. Nennt man es dann einfach beim Namen, sagt Staatstrojaner, das ist generisch.
Na ja, und wir haben ja eigentlich nach der Veröffentlichung gesehen, wie im Innenausschuss etwa eben der BKA-Präsident Zierke darüber gesprochen hat, dass eben der BKA zumindest mit derselben Firma Kontakt hat. Es hält sich ja nicht mehr so richtig auseinander, auch weil es Amtshilfe gibt. Der Zeugkriminalamt hat ja den Länderpolizeien geholfen. Es spielt da offenbar nicht wirklich eine Rolle, ob Land oder Bund ist. Es hat einen Staatstrojaner-Überbegriff.
Stimmt dann auf jeden Fall. Also wie gesagt, der neue Trojaner ist die eine neue Meldung. Dann noch irgendwas mit einem Dokument oder einem Papier, was man lesen konnte?
Ja, wir haben zu der gestrigen Pressemitteilung auch noch eine Art Stellungenname, die die Herstellerfirma Digitask an die Behördenkunden gegeben hat. Vierseitiges Papier. Das haben wir gestern mit öffentlich gestellt, was uns auch zugetragen wurde. Und die Aussagen darin, die also unmittelbar nach unserer Veröffentlichung, nur zwei Tage danach gemacht wurden, sind natürlich teilweise auch sehr hane Büchen. Und man versucht da die eigentlichen Probleme, die wir ja vor allen Dingen auch in der Rechtswidrigkeit sehen und der Funktionalität, die da so versteckt ist und auch teilweise verschleiert wurde. Die sind da so ein bisschen kaschiert und auch so ein bisschen beschönigt. Und deswegen haben wir gleich diese Dokument mit online gestellt.
Also das ist ein Dokument, das ist von der Firma, der sozusagen die diesen Trojaner hergestellt hat. Und die hatte nach eurer Entdeckung diese Firma an die offiziellen Stellen geschrieben.
Da erwartet man ja dann eigentlich, dass so eine Firma in der Zeit dann die Hausaufgaben gemacht hat. Und da so ein bisschen zumindest versucht, Know-how rüber zu bringen oder zu simulieren. Aber sie schreiben da eben so Dinge wie, dass der String, den wir gefunden haben und der eindeutig die Software identifiziert, dass dieses C3POR2D2POE zur Authentifizierung dienen würde. Und sie schwenkt es dann auch wenig später wieder ein, dass das nur die zufälligen Zugriffe auf den Trojaner von den nicht zufälligen unterscheiden soll. Also sie haben noch nicht mal verstanden, was eine Authentifizierung ist.
Okay, wir haben jetzt aber auch schon ein bisschen gesammelt. Also Authentifizierung gibt es, es gibt Zugriffe, es gibt einen Trojaner, der wurde programmiert. Und wir haben die Neuigkeiten jetzt kurz zusammengefasst. Fangen wir doch mal ganz von vorne an. Wenn an dieser Stelle Fragen bei euch auftreten oder ihr eine Meinung loswerden wollt zu eben ihrem Staatstrojaner, vielleicht sowas wie, hey, ist doch super, wenn die Behörden sich darum kümmern, dass die Verbrecher gefangen werden, könnt ihr folgendes tun. Aber ich muss auch gestehen, als ihr den Staatstrojaner veröffentlicht habt, ich war auch ein bisschen böse, dass ihr das so schlecht getimt habt, war ich ja gerade im Urlaub. Ich möchte also diese Chance jetzt nutzen, um mal die Geschichte einmal ganz zusammen zu tragen. Sie beginnt ja immer mit, da kommen Festplatten in braunen Umschlägen.
Eigentlich beginnt sie noch viel früher, viel früher beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, was ja eine Entscheidung getroffen hat.
Ja, am 27. Februar 2008 nämlich schon.
Genau, die eben die Grundlagen oder die Dinge abgesteckt hat, die so ein Ding tun darf und was so ein Ding nicht tun darf. Und da war der CCC auch nicht ganz unbeteiligt.
Ja, wir haben eigentlich auch schon von damals an, es ist lustig, dass jetzt die alten Videos im Netz wieder hochpoppen, immer gesagt, Mensch, wenn ihr so ein Ding habt, wir nehmen das gerne entgegen, das würden wir uns gerne mal ansehen, weil ja schon in der Anhörung zu diesem Urteil davor...
Also, wenn ihr schon ganz am Anfang anfangen wollt, dann müsst ihr noch ganz am Anfang anfangen. Also, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat im Jahre 2008 genau was entschieden?
Also, es ging damals um das nordrhein-wissfedische Verfassungsschutzgesetz, was das erste Gesetz war in Deutschland, wo eine sogenannte Online-Durchsuchung, also ein Spionageprogramm, Trojaner, gesetzlich erlaubt wurde. Und dagegen wurde in Karlsruhe Beschwerde eingelegt, die war erfolgreich. Und dann ging am 27. Februar 2008 das Urteil, wo gleichzeitig auch ein neues Grundrecht konstituiert wurde, nämlich das Grundrecht auf Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von informationstechnischen Systemen. Na wieso? Wir waren noch damals nach dem Chaosradio hier, kannst du dich nicht mehr erinnern?
Erklär's doch nochmal für die Leute, die die Möglichkeit haben, die die Sendung nicht mehr ganz im Kopf haben.
So ein Grundrecht wird ja nicht alle nahe so lang geschaffen. Das passiert irgendwie alle 20, 30 Jahre mal, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht wirklich explizit sagt, wir konstituieren eigentlich ein neues Recht. Das wird dann nicht in einen Gesetzestext eingetreten, sondern das ist dann einfach so was, wenn das Gericht sagt, irgendwie...
Ja, das tritt schon unmittelbar an Kraft.
Das tritt in Kraft, aber es wird jetzt nicht das Grundgesetz hergenommen und dann noch unten dran geschrieben. Sondern es gibt da halt alle Nase lang, aber alle heilige Zeit mal so eine Entscheidung, wo eben festgestellt wird, da ist was, wo man mal klar sagen muss, hier ist die Linie, da brauchen wir ein Grundrecht, und das haben sie dann auch sehr wohlfeil ausformuliert.
Ja, man muss eigentlich sagen, dass die Fragen, die wir heute debattieren, jetzt in der aktuellen Debatte, damals schon auch technisch alle angesprochen wurden. Also wie weit darf man gehen? Welche Gefahren gibt es, wenn man infiltriert einen Rechner?
Genau, das würde ich jetzt gerne noch mal sagen. Wie heißt das? Unverletzlichkeit personalisierter Informationssysteme?
Ich sag, soll ich so mal sagen? Ist das Grundrecht auf Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von informationstechnischen Systemen.
Heißt das, niemand darf meinen Computer anfassen?
Heißt das natürlich so platt, aber es wurde schon festgestellt, dass man eigentlich diese sogenannten ausgelagerten Gehirne, von denen eben auch das Gericht spricht, also unsere Computer und teilweise eben auch Mobiltelefone, weil das ja nicht auf Computer beschränkt, sondern eben informationstechnische Systeme, dass die in der Integrität nicht oder nur unter großen Hürden angegriffen werden dürfen, also infiltriert werden dürfen, und dass natürlich eine Vertraulichkeit gegeben sein sollte, dass man also eine Form von digitaler Intimsphäre haben darf. Ja, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen die Essenz. Natürlich ist es ein langer Dohrteil, steht im Netz, darf man sich gerne durchlesen.
Gibt sogar einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu.
Ja, da gibt es einen eigenen Eintrag.
Das ist insofern sehr weitsichtig gewesen, weil Computer von der erweiterten Schreibmaschine immer mehr zu Geräten werden, die sehr intime Gedanken auch innehalten können, weil man eben nicht alles, was man seinem Computer anvertraut, das verlässt diesen Computer. Man schreibt E-Mails, die man nicht abschickt, weil man sich das noch mal anders überlegt und bestimmte Sachen nicht mitteilt. Man schreibt persönliche Tagebücher, man schreibt irgendwie...
Naja, Bilder, Filme kommen natürlich auch dazu.
Aber im Klartext heißt es sozusagen, dass das Gericht den Behörden verbietet, einfach mal hinzugehen und in den Rechner reinzugucken, also ihn aufzumachen.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig. Das Gesetz wurde verworfen und war dann verfassungswidrig, aber man hat für gewisse Fälle diese Online-Durchsuchung zugelassen. Nämlich bei schwersten Gefahren und solchen Gefahren, die den Staaten seiner Existenz bedrohen. Das ist ungefähr vergleichbar mit dem großen Lauschangriff. Unter ganz großen Hürden darf man auch eine Wanze ins Schlafzimmer packen. So hoch sind ungefähr vergleichbar die Hürden, um eine Computerwanze für die Online-Durchsuchung zu machen, also für die Durchsuchung der Festplatte, wie damals debattiert wurde. Aber gleichzeitig, kurz vor der Anhörung, da war so eine mündliche Anhörung, da zogen plötzlich die Behörden einen neuen Begriff aus der Tasche, nämlich die Quellen-TKÜ, die Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung. Den Begriff hatten wir vorher noch nie gehört, so ein typisches Beamten-Deutsch. Sie machten da eine Art Abgrenzung. Es gibt die Infiltration der Rechner, um die Platte zu durchsuchen und Sachen zu finden. Und es gibt die Infiltration der Rechner, um nur die Telekommunikation, sprich Skype oder Zipgate, also irgendeine Internet-Telefonie, abzuschnorchern.
Also Telekommunikation heißt schon sozusagen, ich rede mit jemand.
Die Begründung war eben das bei regulärer Telekommunikation, die ja im Jahre 2011 immer noch größtenteils unverschlüsselt stattfindet oder mit Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die nicht ganz der Kontrolle des Benutzers unterstehen. Also wenn ich ein Mobiltelefon-Gespräch führe, dann ist das zwar verschlüsselt, aber der Netzbetreiber kann das trotzdem entschlüsseln und an die Daten rankommen.
Das ist ja gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass wir eine Abhörschnittstelle haben.
Genau, da ist eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung sozusagen möglich. Wenn jetzt ein Bedarfsträger an einen Telekommunikationsanbieter rangeht und sagt, wir hätten gerne von dem und dem Kunden von euch mal eine Kopie aller Telefonate, dann müssen die unter bestimmten Voraussetzungen das tun. Und die Begründung für diese sogenannte Quellen-TKÜ, was im Prinzip ein bundestrojaner Leid durch die Hintertüre ist, ist die, dass es Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten gibt, die verschlüsselt sind und die, wo die Verschlüsselung auf dem Endgerät des Benutzers stattfindet. Und dass man da ja nur an der Quelle überwachen könne. Und deswegen in die Datenverarbeitungsanlage, also in den Computer, wo diese Verschlüsselung geschieht, eingreifen müsse und das vor der Verschlüsselung. Und auf der anderen Seite nach der Entschlüsselung.
Okay, ich fasse mal kurz zusammen. Es wurde erlaubt mit diesem Urteil, dass die Behörden hingehen und eine Software auf den Computer einbringen, die genau nur eine Sache macht, nämlich den Audio Stream mitzeichnen und an die Behörden ausliefern.
Ja, nicht ganz. Es gab da noch einen kleinen Pferdefuß, da steckt so ein Satz dahinter, der sagt, das darf man dann tun, wenn man dann aber rechtlich und technisch absichert, rechtlich und technisch absichert, dass eben auch wirklich nur die Telekommunikation ausgeleitet wird. Das ist ein Pferdefuß, ein wichtiger.
Sonst nichts. Die andere Frage, die ich hätte, ist, wir reden ja wahrscheinlich in den meisten Fällen von Skype. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass Skype verrufgeraten ist, weil sie mit den Behörden eher leicht kooperieren. Warum braucht man dann eine Quellen-TKÜ?
Das entlarvt eben gerade die Quellen-TKÜ als Schutzbehauptung sozusagen, weil es eben in der Tat möglich ist, von Firmen wie Skype, die ja auch den Gesetzen unterstehen, eine Ausleitung zu bekommen. Es ist in der Tat so, dass Skype kein Telekommunikationsdienstanbieter ist.
Naja, das ist umstritten, aber die meisten Juristen sagen, es ist wohl keiner, aber das ist ja recht umstritten.
Sie sind nichtsdestotrotz im Besitz der Schlüsse für diese Kommunikation. Und mit den Schlüsseln und dem abgehörten Datenverkehr kann man in jedem Fall das wieder rekonstruieren. Also unterm Strich gäbe es schon eine Möglichkeit, an diese Informationen und an diese Kommunikationsinhalte heranzukommen, ohne gleich diesen Staatstrojaner aufspielen zu müssen.
Aber war das nicht auch so, dass Skype selber gesagt hat, kommt doch einfach her und macht, oder bilde ich mir das gerade noch ein?
Sie hatten das auf ihrer Webseite sogar. Ich glaube, die hat sich jetzt verändert. Die sind ja von Microsoft gekauft worden. Ist ja schon ein bisschen her, ich glaube ein paar Monate. Früher stand das direkt auf ihrer Webseite, natürlich. Also es ist ja auch ein Hinweis an die Benutzer letztlich, dass man mit den Strafverfolgungsbehörden zusammenarbeitet.
Okay, also es gibt diesen Pferdefuß, den du gerade genannt hast, es gibt diese Software, die soll nur können den Autostreamer abgreifen und das muss rechtlich und technisch gesichert sein. Die rechtliche Seite ist, oder würde man sagen, okay, dann dürfen sich da gerne die Juristen hinsetzen, sich irgendwas ausdenken.
Die ist auch nochmal kritisch, aber wir sind ja schließlich Hacker und keine Jurist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, jetzt stelle ich mir es schwierig vor, bis unmöglich zu beweisen, dass etwas, also oder andersherum gefragt, wie macht man das? Also wie beweise ich das an der Software, technisch nur genau die Dinge kann, die sie können?
Es ist ja einfach nachzuweisen, dass ein Software bestimmte Dinge kann, so geht es durchaus, aber es ist ungleich schwieriger, gerade auch wenn sie im Quellcode nicht vorhanden ist, sondern man sich nur wirklich das, was auf diesem Computer liegt und ausgeführt wird, anschaut. Und das ist auch schwierig, sich aus dem Quellcode wirklich zu beweisen oder zu erschließen. Das tut wirklich nicht mehr. Da muss man nämlich von ausgehen, dass in der Quellcode, wenn man ihn so liest, wirklich das tut, was man glaubt, dass er tut und dass der Programmierer da keine bösen Intentionen hat und da eventuell Dinge versteckt hat. Also es ist sehr einfach nachzuweisen, dass eine Software was macht, aber dass eine Software wirklich eine Funktionalität nicht hat oder dass auch durch die Hintertüre, beispielsweise durch einen Programmierfehler, nicht möglich ist, bestimmte Funktionalitäten dieser Software so auszunutzen, dass sie doch andere Dinge tut, das kann man schwerlich nachweisen.
Jetzt haben die Richter das aber da reingeschrieben, das soll technisch sichergestellt sein. Haben die das da gewusst?
Na ja, es wurde natürlich schon damals darüber gesprochen, dass das letztlich auch ein theoretisches Informatikproblem ist, was eben letztlich ungelöst ist, klar. Aber nun könnte man ja sagen, man muss es nicht unbedingt jetzt informationstechnisch sehen. Man muss jetzt nicht sagen, ok, wir reden über das sogenannte alte Problem. Also wie löst man so theoretische Informatikprobleme? Man könnte einfach überlegen, wie man es trotzdem technisch so gestalten könnte, dass man mit großer Sicherheit sagen kann, die Software tut etwas nicht. Da gibt es natürlich Varianten. Zum einen natürlich ein guter Quellcode, der natürlich den Behörden vorliegt und letztlich irgendwann dann den Betroffenen, damit er sich wehren kann. Ja, der gut dokumentiert ist. Wäre eine Möglichkeit, eine allererste. Und natürlich muss man trotzdem auch Funktionstests machen, klar. Und möglichst eben so gut testen, dass auch die Fehlerfreiheit zumindest reduziert werden kann. Also klar, größere Software hat immer Fehler, lässt sich wohl nicht hindern. Also das heißt, man müsste mit mehreren verschiedenen prozessualen Schritten versuchen, diese Probleme der Informatik zu umschiffen in gewisser Weise und zu hoffen, dass man eben wenig Fehler macht und die Nachvorziehbarkeit und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das hinter der Tür eingebaut ist, gering lässt. Das ist natürlich letztlich theoretisch ein unlösbares Problem.
Aber ich entnehme euren Worten erst mal. Wenn so was passiert, muss auf jeden Fall der Quellcode zu dem Programm vorliegen, damit man sich ihn antun kann. Quellcode, vielleicht für die Leute, die noch dazuhören, nicht wissen, was das ist, ist der menschenlesbare Teil eines Programms.
Dass man dann wieder aus einem Programmierer in seine Tastatur tippt, das ist der Quellcode.
Wir haben da natürlich nichts getippt, das Programm. Die Trojaner sind in C++ geschrieben. Aber wir hatten ja nicht der Quellcode, wir hatten die Binärdateien.
Dazu kommen wir gleich. Aus dem Quellcode kann man dann ein Programm übersetzen, was der Computer wirklich ausführt. Was ich mich jetzt immer frage, ist, wie man schreibt ein Programm und gibt dir das fertig Programm, also das sogenannte Binärprogramm, und sagt so, guck mal, und hier ist der Quellcode dazu. Woher weiß ich dann, dass dieses Programm, das ich habe, und dieser Quellcode, den ich habe, dass die wirklich zueinander gehören und dass nicht der Quellcode was ganz anderes ist? Wie kann ich das feststellen?
Indem man sich einfach den Quellcode nochmal selber übersetzt und das dann verwendet. Weil idealerweise vertraut man nur dem, was man halt sieht. Die eigentliche Krux ist, dass wenn man sich sowas anschauen wollen würde und wenn diese Firma wirklich den Quellcode weitergegeben hätte, dann müsste trotzdem auf der Seite der Behörden das Know-how da sein, sich das überhaupt anschauen zu können und da eine Abschätzung zu treffen, auch nur ungefähr zu sehen, ist das total amurks, was die da veranstaltet haben. Können wir das einsetzen? Und ich wage zu behaupten, dass wenn das Know-how auf deren Seite da gewesen wäre und auch die rechtliche Kenntnis von den Einschränkungen, dann wäre das so nie zum Einsatz gekommen, weil da eben Dinge drin sind, die deutlich über die eng gesteckten Grenzen hinausgehen.
Also ein auch technischer Murks teilweise. Das ist ja einmal die Seite der Rechtsbrüche, die dort begangen wurden, aber andererseits natürlich auch wirklich der schlechte Code.
Ich fand die Frage jetzt gerade so ganz entsetzt, dass ich die Frage gestellt habe. Das ist natürlich von daher interessant, weil die meisten Leute denken, so ein Programm, die laden das ja immer noch runter und sagen, sich selber besetzen ist jetzt nicht so verbreitet. Aber das hätten die Behörden leisten müssen. Sie hätten also sagen, eigentlich nur beauftragen können, schreib mal das Programm, gib uns dann den Quellcode und wir übersetzen das selber und haben es vorher noch nachgeprüft.
Dann kann man sich fragen, warum gibt es diese Partnerfirma, die sind Trojaner, da baut eigentlich die Quellcode nicht raus, was wir vielleicht in einer normalen Sache finden würden. Aber da gibt es natürlich einige Gründe, da kann man spekulieren. Und eine ist, das ist natürlich ihr Geschäftsgeheimnis. Dafür haben sie Arbeit reingesteckt und wollen es vielleicht behalten. Denn die Behörden, wie soll man das sagen, sie sind in gewisser Weise dafür bekannt, dass sie schon mal... Ja, und auch Software, die sie so bekommen haben, dann schon mal weiterverwenden. Solche Fälle soll es ja gegeben haben. Das heißt, es gibt auch Softwareklau im Behördenbereich. Insofern, die wollten sich wohl doppelt schützen. Aber man könnte natürlich auch andersrum spekulieren. Man könnte sagen, naja, die Fehler, die drin sind, die kann man damit natürlich kaschieren, wenn derjenige den Quellcode gar nicht bekommt. Oder aber auch die Verschleierung, denn Teile der Funktionalität sind ja verschleiert, kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf. Das kann man natürlich viel besser verbergen.
Wenn man sagt, wir wussten von nichts, wir haben die den Quellcode bekommen, da kann man plötzlich mehr machen.
Ich möchte noch mal kurz ins Jahr 2008 zurückkehren. Es gibt also dieses Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht. Das sagt, so eine Software darf nur eingesetzt werden, wenn technisch und rechtlich sichergestellt ist, dass sie nur den Audio-Stream abgreift und sonst nicht. Wir haben gerade lang und ausführlich erklärt, warum das eher schwierig ist, umzusetzen. Du hast das vorhin schon kurz erwähnt. Ihr habt damals schon gesagt, na ja, wenn ihr so ein Ding findet, schickt uns mal.
Letztlich alle fünf technischen Gutachter, die damals gerichtet sind, also eine davon waren wir, aber da waren eben noch andere technische Gutachter, die haben eigentlich alle dieses Problem schon aufgeworfen. Wir haben damals eben schon gesagt, würden wir uns auch gerne mal praktisch angucken? Dann gab es dann wenig später auch den ersten Fall, da war diese, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch erinnert, diese Spiegelreporterin, die online durchsucht wurde, weil so ein bisschen der Fall damals durch die Presse ging, weil sie in Afghanistan recherchiert hatte und irgendwie ein Ministerium, ein Außenministerium in Afghanistan mit betroffen war, weil so ein bisschen diplomatische Affäre. Da war ja klar, es gibt diese Software schon, die hätten wir natürlich auch gerne zur Untersuchung gehabt.
Okay, und wie das passiert ist und was dann wirklich passiert ist, das klären wir gleich. Und heute ist es das Chaosradio. Folge 173 dreht sich um den Staatstrojaner. Also die Software von der Behörde denken, dass es möglicherweise eine gute Idee sein könnte, uns damit auszuspionieren. Und wir haben am Anfang der Sendung geklärt, dass dieser Staatstrojaner die Geschichte, die wir heute hier erzählen, Anfang hat, 2008, wo das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat, so Leute Software auf Computer einbringen ist nicht so geil. Ihr dürft das nur machen, wenn ihr da mit Audio abhören wollt. Und dann müsst ihr auch sicherstellen, dass diese Software genau nur das macht.
Nicht Audio, Kommunikation.
Ich hab extra vorne gefragt, ob Telekommunikation heißt, dass ich miteinander rede.
Ja, aber Audio kann ja auch zum Beispiel sein. Ich nehme mir selber mein, puh, Gespräche, aber ich mach im Podcast die nicht veröffentliche.
Also gut, ihr dürft nur das Audio von Telekommunikationsferngesprächen auf dem Computer abgreifen und sonst nichts. Und da hat der CCC dann damals schon gesagt, na, das glauben wir nicht so richtig, dass es passiert. Schickt uns doch mal so eine Teile ein, falls ihr die irgendwo findet. Ihr könnt während der Sendung auch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110, falls ihr Fragen habt oder falls ihr eine Meinung loswerden wollt.
Genau, und der Dortmunder, der eben in den Nachrichten anrufen wollte, den bitten wir doch mal zu probieren, weil der Einbeinige war gerade außer Gefecht und konnte nicht ans Telefon gehen.
Der Einbeinige arbeitet nur, wenn Holgi hier ist übrigens.
Genau. Achso.
Nee, das ist heute. Heute hat er zwei Beine.
Aber der war doch einbeinig.
Nee, nee, nee, das siehst du völlig falsch.
Entschuldigung. Also bitte nochmal anrufen, Herr Dortmund.
Das kann schon mal passieren. So.
Frau Dortmund.
Wer weiß das schon. Wie gesagt, ihr habt gesagt, ihr habt gesagt, das soll doch mal jemand einschicken. Dann sind tatsächlich anscheinend auf irgendeine seltsame Art und Weise zu euch irgendwelche Festplatten gekommen. Wie geht das von Schatten? Nachts im Stadtpark, Leute mit Aktentaschen? Oder wie passiert das?
Nee, du, ich hab da was.
Na ja, es gab verschiedene Kontaktversuche. Man muss schon sehen, dass in den Fällen, wo wir kontaktiert wurden, natürlich zum einen in der Regel Betroffene dahinter stehen. Also solche, gegen die eben tatsächlich ermittelt wird. Sonst hat man ja in der Regel so einen Staatstrojaner nicht auf der Platte. Und da haben wir verschiedene Arten beobachtet, wie wir kontaktiert wurden. Teilweise eben auch nicht direkt, sondern indirekt. Also man hat eine Person seines Vertrauens genommen, die hat dann über die klassische Telefonzelle mit uns Kontakt aufgenommen und dann eben den braunen Umschlag, also es waren teilweise schon krude Wege. Aber letztlich hatten wir schon auch Kontakt und haben uns unterhalten, weil wir ja natürlich auch sichergehen wollen, dass wir nicht irgendeinem Spinner aufsitzen, sondern eben wirklich mit jemandem, der das ernst meint. Und letztlich, wir hatten so gute Belege dafür, dass wir zumindest mehrere Diversionen sicher als Staatstrojaner identifizieren konnten. Sonst wären wir damit ja auch nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen. Und wir hatten eigentlich auch ganz gute technische Belege, denn dieser Trojaner ist einfach auch technisch anders, als die Trojaner, denen man üblicherweise begegnet.
Das ist ja meistens ein Software, die für professionelle Dinge genutzt wird.
Ich möchte gerne sozusagen, dass wir nicht so schnell vorgehen, ihr habt jetzt diese Festplatte. Diese Festplatte habt ihr von jemanden bekommen, der sagt, okay, ich glaube, ich werde hier verfolgt.
Nein, natürlich waren es dann die Anwälte.
Ja, na gut. Aber ihr habt diese Festplatte und es ist glaubwürdig, dass ihr sagt, ihr guckt euch das mal an. Was ist das jetzt? Ist das eine Festplatte, die hat einfach jemand aus seinem Rechner rausgenommen?
Das war unterschiedlich. Manchmal war es eine Festplatte, manchmal war es der ganze Rechner, der uns gegeben wurde. Dann haben wir eine Image gemacht und haben uns dann angesehen.
Und dann habt ihr eine Festplatte von einem ganz neuen Typen, der so voller Zeug ist.
Wie genau? Wir haben natürlich auch solche Sachen zugesichert, wie dass niemand in den privaten Daten rumwürdet. Das ist natürlich auch klar, dass der uns sein ausgelagertes Gehirn gegeben hat. Das war für uns natürlich überhaupt keine Frage. Wir haben sie auch nicht im Club verteilt, sondern ein kleines Team hat daran gearbeitet.
Sehr ehrenwert. Aber das ist genau die Frage, die ich genau wollte. Ihr habt jetzt eine Festplatte voll erzeugt, dass es einfach nur eine Festplatte ist. Wo genau wisst ihr denn, dass da ein Trojaner ist?
Die Reverse-Engineering-Frage, naja.
Also Reverse-Engineering, um das kurz zu sagen, man hat den Trojaner schon. Und man versucht dann zu untersuchen, was dieses Programm macht. Aber vorher muss man das Programm ja gefunden haben überhaupt.
Es gibt halt eine Handvoll Wege, wie man so eine Software in einem System verankert, dass sie automatisch gestartet wird und so weiter. Das kennt man auch von üblicher Malware, also Software, die auf Computern läuft, die eben da nicht drauf laufen, sondern böse Dinge tut. Da gibt es professionelle Software-Stücke, die zum Spam-Versenden verwendet werden, die dazu verwendet werden, irgendwelche Werbung anzuzeigen, die dazu verwendet werden, den Computer für irgendwelche Angriffe zu missbrauchen und so weiter. Und das ist, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, in der Regel deutlich professionellere, besser verstecktere und sauberer geschriebenere Software.
Da ist nichts implementiert, üblicherweise, was irgendwie restriktiv ist. Weil hier hat man schon gesehen...
Leute, wir wollen erst mal wissen, wie man so einen Trojaner auf einer Festbank überhaupt findet. Ganz der Reihe nach, ganz langsam.
Guckt man sich eben an, was da so gestartet wird, und wenn da Dinge dabei sind, die einem in Spanisch vorkommen, dann guckt man sich das ein bisschen genauer an.
Man sucht nach Prozessen, die typisch sind.
Es gibt also sagen, in einem Betriebssystem bestimmte Orte, wo man gucken kann, ob etwas gestartet wird, was da nicht hingehört.
Wir hatten natürlich auch schon gewissen Verdacht, wo man suchen muss. Wo typischerweise angesetzt wird, wenn man so einen Trojaner aufspielt. Da guckt man natürlich dann... Ich meine, es ist ja für jemanden, der so etwas regelmäßig macht, jetzt auch kein Voodoo.
Ich versuche es ja für die ganzen anderen Leute zu erklären. Deswegen frage ich so detailliert und kleinteilig nach.
Mir scheint, dass Markus in Zukunft da neue Karrieren plant, oder?
Ich möchte darüber jetzt nicht weiter reden. Was ich aber lieber wissen würde, ist ein kleiner Randfakt. Waren das alles Windows-Systeme?
Ja, alles Windows-Systeme. Der alte war 32-bit, also ein älteres Windows. Wir haben bisher keine Hinweise zu Staatstrojaner für freie Betriebssysteme oder für Macs gibt, oder Android-Telefone.
Vielleicht haben sie da fäge Leute beauftragt.
Wir wissen es nicht, wer welche hat. Da sind wir durchaus bereit.
Brauch eine Umschlag, ihr wisst Bescheid. Wir haben jetzt noch ein paar Anrufe in der Leitung. Ich würde vorher gerne diesen einen Punkt zu Ende machen. Ihr habt jetzt rausgefunden, in diesem Betriebssystem, was ihr da untersucht, in diesem System, da gibt es etwas, was da nicht hingehört. Dann habt ihr tatsächlich sozusagen, also eines dieser Binärprogramme, hat man tatsächlich ein Programm, was man untersuchen kann und das ist dann auch nochmal verteilt?
Na, man muss sich schon ein bisschen die Fragmente zusammensuchen, denn versucht wurde schon, von dem Aservat, also dem zurückgegebenen Computer, wurde schon versucht, diese Software zu löschen. Das war halt noch nicht korrekt gelöscht.
Also sagen, das eigentliche Programm war gelöscht, aber ihr konntet das wiederum rekonstruieren?
Genau, also es war nicht ganz vollständig, zumindest haben wir das am Anfang geglaubt, aber Gott sei Dank hatten wir auch mehrere Varianten, um zu vergleichen.
Also jetzt muss ich kurz da noch mal genauer nachfragen. Was ich über gelöschte Dateien wieder herstellen weiß ist folgendes, wenn ein Betriebssystem ein Dateil löscht, löscht es nicht wirklich die Daten auf der Platte, sondern schneidet in dem Inhaltsverzeichnis, einfach sozusagen löscht es das raus, aber die eigentlichen Daten sind noch da. War es so einfach zu rekonstruieren oder war es noch komplizierter?
Nee, es war schon relativ einfach.
Man kann Daten schon wirklich löschen, indem man sie überschreibt.
Da muss man halt wissen, wie es geht.
Wir haben tatsächlich mit einer gewissen Überraschung darauf reagiert, weil wir natürlich auch nicht dachten, dass wir sich so wilder anstellen, um es mal eins offen zu sagen. Wir hatten schon erwartet, dass wir das Programm löschen können. Das würde man ja eigentlich von einem Azubi erwarten können.
War das möglicherweise ein Unfall oder war das wirklich Unfähigkeit?
Ja, da kann man viel darüber spekulieren. Vielleicht ist es auch irgendwie in der Haste passiert. Vielleicht hat da einfach niemand drüber geguckt. Vielleicht haben sie einfach gedacht, da guckt sowieso niemand an. Da können wir nur spekulieren, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht wollten sie auch gerne dem CCC entgegenarbeiten. Vielleicht war da der Berühmte mit dem gewissen Spissen in der Behörde. Wir wissen es nicht.
Jetzt habt ihr also sagen dann tatsächlich dieses Programm gefunden, also diesen Trojaner und wie genau habt ihr dann herausgefunden, was der macht? Das heißt sagen, wie gesagt, nur dieser Blob von Binärcode?
Also das eine ist, dass es natürlich heute eine Menge Hilfsmittel gibt, um so ein Reverse Engineering zu machen, also nachdrücklich also hintenrum quasi die Funktionitäten des Programmierers auszufinden. Da gibt es heute eine Menge Software für, die natürlich auch echt professionelle Hilfe leistet und einem die Sache erleichtert, diesen Maschinencode zu, ja eigentlich wieder zusammenzusetzen in die ursprüngliche Funktion.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass ja so ein Software auch irgendwie aufgespielt werden muss und das passiert dann, wenn der Benutzer ja sein Gerät mal aus der Hand gibt oder jemand bei dem Benutzer zu Hause eben ja in die Wohnung reingeht und das auf den Computer aufspielt.
Da haben wir auch gefragt, schon vorher, wie das passiert ist. Wir wollten natürlich da gerne hören, ob der Mandant, ja wie er sich vorstellt, wie das auf den Rechner gekommen ist.
Und um sowas dann zu tun, gibt es einen sogenannten Dropper. Also das ist eine Software, die man raufkopiert oder von USB-Stick startet, die dann eben in einem bestimmten Stellensystem das Ding versteckt und dafür sorgt, dass das automatisch gestartet wird.
Kann auch nur ein CD sein, aber jedenfalls irgendwie muss man den Dropper platzieren.
Aber tatsächlich sozusagen haben die Leute...
Ist so was wie ein Installationsprogramm...
.physikalischer Kontakt zu dem Rechner. Sie haben uns sozusagen übers Netz gehackt.
Also es gibt Hinweise, dass nicht alle Trojaner... Also wir wissen noch nicht genau, die wir... Wo wir es wissen, waren es zwei fingierte Zollkontrollen. Das heißt bei der Ausreise, der ist weggeflogen aus München, haben sie eine Zollkontrolle fingiert und erst mal rausgekriegt, was ist das denn für ein Windows. Also man muss es ja schon anpassen. Und bei der Rückreise haben sie die nochmal abgenommen und eine Zollkontrolle fingiert und dann haben sie eben den Droper raufgetan.
Und denen hat lustigerweise diese Firma vorher bei einem Testdienst eingereicht. Es gibt von Antivirenherstellern so einen Testdienst, wo man eben bestimmte Dateien hochladen kann. Und dann wird das gegen alle möglichen Antivirenprogramme geworfen und einem halt gesagt, dass und das Programm meldet, das und das oder keins der Programme meldet. Irgendwas hat man eine lange Liste, wo man dann eben gucken kann, wie verhalten sich diese Programme. Und normalerweise in einer professionellen Mailware-Entwicklung baut man sich sowas halt selbst, weil man irgendwie halt einen Hindernisparcours hat, wo man den Kram reinwirft. Und es gibt sowas aber auch in öffentlich als Forschungsprojekt von eben Antivirenherstellern. Auch mit der Ansage, wir gucken uns das an, was ihr uns einsendet. Und sie haben in der Tat ihren Dropper da einmal durchlaufen lassen. Und damit hatten alle Antivirenhersteller halt einmal dieses Dropper-Binary.
Aber da haben wir natürlich schon irgendwie facial paimiert. Also da war es schon ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Das tut echt weh. Also wenn man sieht, dass die das auf einer Seite hochladen, wo schon drunter steht irgendwie, alles was hier hochgeladen wird, wird auch irgendwann mal analysiert werden, wenn uns das interessiert.
Da muss man schon wirklich auch an der Professionalität zweifeln.
Die Erkenntnis von diesen Leuten, hatte die auch zur Verfügung?
Das ist glaube ich irgendwann mal... Also die Antivirenhersteller wussten zumindest schon davon, dass es das gibt wohl. Also da kam hinten ein Mensch, da war doch sowas oder so. Ich weiß es nicht, wie das jetzt genau zeitlich einzuordnen ist, aber Fakt ist, sie haben das da hochgeladen.
Extremverpeilung, könnte man sagen. Aber das war nur das Installationsprogramm. Also nochmal für Anfang erklärt, wie genau reverse-ingeniert man den eigentlichen Trojaner. Dann findet dann eine Art Rückübersetzung statt, dass man dann noch einmal den Programmcode hat.
Der Programmcode ist ja grundsätzlich was, was von einer Maschine interpretiert wird. Und sehr genau das, was da passiert, beschreibt. Und das kann man wiederum nicht nur von einer Maschine ausführen lassen, sondern das kann man sich halt auch angucken, was passiert da mit dieser Maschine, und sich das zusammen puzzeln. Das war dann auch das, was in der FAZ am Sonntag veröffentlicht war, auf diesen vielen, vielen Seiten grundbedrücktes Papier.
Wir haben es jetzt aber auch gestern komplett veröffentlicht. Das heißt, die sogenannten IDADBs, die kann man sich jetzt und die Binaries, die kann man sich runterladen und selbst analysieren, weil wir fordern auch unsere Community, aber auch jeder, der irgendwie Lust und Bock drauf hat. Denn das ist nicht vollständig und die Analyse muss noch komplettiert werden. Und wir erwarten da auch hoffentlich ein bisschen Mithilfe, haben wir auch schon teilweise bekommen von unserer größeren Community, aber auch von allen technisch Interessierten.
Also der umgedrehte Schritt, den wir vorhin schon erläutert haben, ist, man hat einen Quellcode, der ist menschenlesbarer und der übersetzt sich in dieses Binary. Und der umgedrehte Weg, den ihr gerade beschreibt, ist aber so der Quellcode, der daraus kommt, ist eher sozusagen 010101 als tatsächlich was menschenlesbares.
Man kann das dann aber, die Software, die wir eingesetzt haben, das ist IDA, also das nennt sich Interaktiver Disassembler. Sprich, man bekommt dann das, was da Binarycode ist, aufgeschlüsselt in Befehle, die eben auf diesem Computer rausgeführt werden, sehr kleinschrittig, und kann sich das dann halt zusammenbröckeln und kommentieren und hin und her schieben und gucken, was gehört wie zusammen, wo wird in dem Programm rumgesprungen, was passiert da so?
Also man sucht die Pointer, wo zeigen die hin. Wer ein bisschen Erfahrung damit hat, der wird natürlich gewisse Muster wiedererkennen. Also das ist so ein bisschen eine Kombination aus maschineller Hilfe, aber auch eigener Erfahrung, die natürlich mit jedem Reverse-Entoneering-Projekt, was man gemacht hat, steigt.
Darf ich mal ein analogisches Bild versuchen?
Versuch's doch.
Jemand gibt euch eine Armbanduhr, die noch mechanisch funktioniert, aber er gibt euch nur die Einzelteile. Und dann müsst ihr das zusammen puzzeln. Ist das ungefähr so?
Das ist eigentlich nicht so ein guter Vergleich. Ein Programm ist ja nicht so, dass man das zusammenbaut. Das ist ein fertiges Stück, sondern da gibt es ja Interdependenzen. Ich finde den Vergleich nicht so gut. Wie findest du den, Nibbler?
Ja, ist schwierig.
Wir sind dagegen.
Es ist ungefähr so, als würde man dir jetzt in einmal Einsen, einmal Nullen hinstellen sagen, das war vielleicht mein...
Ich finde es keinen guten Vergleich. Wir streichen den mal.
Wir haben einen Anrufer, der sich damit vielleicht auskennt. Welchen?
Welchen der drei?
Nummer zwei. Wir können ja mal Christian fragen.
Hallo Christian.
Hast du schon mal Ida benutzt?
Ja, ich hab mich damit auseinandergesetzt.
Findest du den Uhrenvergleich von Markus gut?
Naja, wenn wir eine komplette, zusammengebaute Uhr kriegen und sagen, so, jetzt guck mal, wie die funktioniert, dann vielleicht.
Ja, so rum... Naja, schon besser als Markus.
In den Urlaub von hinten reingucken und sagen, guck mal, was ist denn das? Und dann sagen, das könnte eine Uhr sein.
Okay, wir streichen jetzt den Uhrenvergleich, Christian. Erklär mal bitte jemanden, also jemand kommt zu dir, dem du sehr gewogen bist und der fragt dich wirklich mit großen Augen so, du Reverse-Engineering, wie funktioniert das? Was ist das, was macht das?
Ja, schwierig, bin nicht so der Reverse-Engineer, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Was lernst du denn im IT-Security-Studium dann?
Eigentlich geht es nur darum, dass da Sicherheit nichts mit vertrauen, sondern eher was mit Misstrauen zu tun hat, sagt unser Dozent immer.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine alte Weisheit, da hast du recht.
Ja, wir haben einen etwas fitteren Prof, was das angeht.
Wer ist denn das?
Das ist der Prof. Dr. Quade.
Aha, dann kommst du aus irgendwo bei Karlsruhe, oder? Krefeld, naja, dann weiß ich es nicht.
Und er macht das etwas spielerisch mit dem IT-Security. Das heißt, wir dürfen uns auch gegenseitig in den Versuchen hacken.
Habt ihr auch mal versucht, euch gegenseitig, wenn ihr irgendwie Code schreibt, Sachen zu verstecken, also Hintertüren einzubauen, die dann derjenige, der den Quellcode least, nicht findet oder nur schwer findet?
Ja, es geht darum, wir haben Linux-Systeme, die müssen wir im Praktikum absichern und gleichzeitig bei den anderen Leuten einbrechen und Code klauen.
Großartig.
Und die müssen wir dann in ein System eingeben. Dieses System zählt dann die Punkte. Wir haben halt verschiedene Dienste laufen müssen, und wenn die Dienste abstürzen aufgrund des Hackens, kriegen wir Minuspunkte.
Genau.
Und es geht halt darum, am Ende bei null Punkten zu bleiben, um das Praktikum zu bestehen.
Ja, vollkommen klar. Ich muss dir jetzt mal grad die ethische Frage stellen. Würdest du für so eine Software-Klitsche wie DigiTask arbeiten und eine Shard-Sofer für den Starten?
Na ja, da fehlt mir die Professionalität, glaube ich.
Na hey, da wärst du doch da aber richtig.
Also, ja, das ist schwierig zu sagen. Wir haben auch gleichzeitig mit dem IT-Secret einen Kurs Recht und Ethik gestartet, den wir verpflichtend besuchen müssen. Das heißt, man kann es nicht nur das Hacken beibringen, sondern auch gleich die moralischen Grundlagen dafür.
Und wenn man da einmal durchgegangen ist durch diesen Kurs, dann weiß man, dass man nicht bei so einer Firma anfängt, oder?
Ja, das ist schwierig zu sagen, weil auf der einen Seite muss man ja auch sein eigenes Überleben, also auch Geld sichern für die Familie und für sein eigenes Wohempfinden. Und auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich abwiegen, wie fern man sich den Grundrechten verpflichtet fühlt.
Deswegen riefst du eigentlich an, Nummer, Nummer kurz.
Eigentlich wollte ich anrufen, weil unser Professor hat sich halt auch über den Bundestrojaner etwas ausgelassen. Also Staatstrojaner, Entschuldigung. Und er meinte, das wäre wohl eine der nicht so brillantesten Software, die er je gesehen hat.
Tja, da hat er wohl recht.
Und er beschwert sich halt über die fehlende Linux-Umsetzung.
Aber heute hat doch, ach so, er beschwert sich, heute hat doch unser Innenspezialexperte Ull von der Union gesagt, sie würden beim Bund alle digitalsten Leute gerne einstellen.
Das hab ich auch bei Tiefel gelesen, das fand ich sehr knuffig. Also da finden sich direkt die richtigen Profis, würd ich sagen.
Also letztlich bestätigst du uns qua der Aussage deines Professors, dass tatsächlich die Software Fehler hat und nicht gerade der Creme oder der Creme ist.
Ich hab im Studium ja nicht unbedingt die Leuchte im Programmieren und so, weil da fehlt mir noch ein bisschen die Erfahrung, aber selbst ich hab festgestellt, dass einige von den Sachen durch kluges Nachdenken hätten vermeiden werden können. Also allein, dass die den Kanal nicht richtig verschlüsselt oder nur leicht verschlüsselt haben, dass man sich da eigentlich beliebig anmelden kann und sich nicht wirklich autofenzieren muss.
Ich hab's jetzt heute auch nicht.
Authentifizieren. Genau, da haben wir auch einen schönen Kurs über Zugangskontrollen gehabt. Da haben wir dann ein schönes Lied zugehört. A ist for Autification.
Hmhmhm, singt er Lieder. Ja, na gut, Details, wir die vielleicht nicht wissen wollen.
Möchte ich noch mal kurz fragen, welches Semester oder welches Jahr bist du da? Fünften Semester, du kannst du sagen schon aus eigener Hand beurteilen, dass das nicht so das Goldene vom Ei ist, was sie dir abgeliefert haben.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Also wir haben schon im ersten Semester Grundlagen der guten Programmierung kennengelernt.
Alles klar. Also liebe DigiTask, wir haben die Telefonnummer von Christian hier. Ihr könnt gerne anrufen, der kann euch vielleicht noch was beibringen. Christian, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. So, dann haben wir noch jemand, der in der technischen Richtung unterwegs ist. Das ist der Johnny. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Wozu möchtest du etwas sagen zum Staatstrojaner?
Na ja, vielleicht kann ich Constanze noch kurz auf die Sprünge helfen. Der Kollege aus Karlsruhe ist der Herr Müller-Quade.
Jetzt der mit der Pflege. Ich hab's leider verwechselt. Entschuldigung.
Okay, keine Insider bitte.
Es gibt nicht so viele Informatik-Profis, die Quade heißen.
Und zwar hatte ich in den, na ja, bei den Online-Zeitungen und so weiter gelesen, dass Kaspersky ebenfalls ganz stolz so sein Stückchen zur Analyse beigetragen hat und eine Jeste mit Programmen veröffentlichte, auf die zugegriffen wird. Ich weiß nicht, sie haben sich über die technischen Details ein bisschen ausgeschwiegen. Aber eins ist uns ins Auge gestochen und zwar der Explorer-Exe. Ich erkläre das kurz, das ist dieses Programm, das dem Windows-Benutzer erlaubt, die Dateien auf seinem Rechner anzuklicken. Und es kann aber noch deutlich mehr, das macht nicht nur Dateiverwaltung, sondern halt auch Systemeinstellungen und es kann sogar ein bisschen im Internet surfen, nicht so wirklich, aber es ist eine Menge drin. Und jetzt wollte ich quasi fragen, wisst ihr da mehr drüber? Wir hatten uns gefragt, kann diese Trojaner tatsächlich unsere Daten schon alle lesen?
Na, also der Hinweis darauf, dass auch in der alten Version, also in der ersten, die wir veröffentlicht haben, bereits der Explorer dabei war, den hatten wir schon. Es gibt da quasi in den Benährdaten eine ganze Liste von Programmen, die eben, ja, die da runterfallen können. Das sind aber nicht alle Programme, auf die auch zugegriffen wurde, sondern eben die auch teilweise nur drin waren als Module.
Warte, nochmal, also diese Software hat die Fähigkeit, auf bestimmte andere Programme zuzugreifen und die zu steuern?
Das kann jedes Programm, das mit entsprechenden Berechtigungen ausgeschaltet ist.
Ja, genau, aber beim Freitag die Frage bei Staatstrojaner ist ja, ist er das?
Die Antwort ist ja und alles, was du dazu brauchst, ist im Prinzip die Möglichkeit, eigene Threads zu erzeugen, die dann mit den anderen Programmen zu interagieren. Also prinzipiell ist es durchaus möglich, innerhalb von Windows mit vielen anderen Programmen gleichzeitig zu sprechen.
Genau, der Staatstrojaner kann jetzt genau mit welchen Programmen, sozusagen kann er an welche Programme andocken und die mitbenutzen?
Also die abschließende Liste habe ich nicht im Kopf, aber es waren, oh ja, also zwei, drei Dutzend. Also es war natürlich auch eine Liste von, wenn ich mich da recht in den Sinne, die verschiedenen Voice-over-IP-Programme betreffen. Also es waren nicht nur Skype und verschiedene Browser. Ich glaube, da waren, boah, also es war eine Liste, ich würde mal sagen, zwei Dutzend, ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Und da bestrich ich auch im Prinzip keine Rolle, weil, wie ja, der, wie man das selbst zugegeben hat, kann man da in der Tat auch Programme nachladen. Wir haben das in einem Video, das kann man sich auf ccc.de verlinkt, gezeigt, dass man beispielsweise den Windows-Taschenrechner ausführen kann damit.
Also ein beliebiges Programm, also wir haben es nur als Beispiel genommen.
Also da sieht man halt, wie das hochgeladen wird, das Programm, also dieser Taschenrechner, und dann auf dem Rechner ausgeführt wird, um das mal so als Beispiel zu machen.
Politisch ist es sozusagen der Skandal eigentlich, nämlich das...
Das ist der Skandal und die Erklärung, die dann abgeliefert wurde, ja, aber wenn man das alles überwachen würde, dann könnte man ja nachweisen, dass das geschehen ist. Ja, wenn. Also wenn man das dann dokumentieren würde, was damit alles passiert und wenn man sichergehen könnte, dass nur der Befugte, der das Ding bedienen darf, das macht und dass der wirklich hundertprozentig und immer überwacht wird und das kann man einfach nicht.
Also nochmal, um sozusagen zum Anfang der halben Stunde zurückzukommen, es gab ja diese Verfassungsgerichtsurteil, das gesagt hat, technisch nur diese eine Sache. Jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt angekommen, wo ihr sagt, der Staatsstrojaner kann aber viel mehr. Es ist also gerade technisch nicht sichergestellt, dass der nur diese...
Natürlich, an mehreren Ecken und Enden. Also es war ja nicht nur so, dass die Funktionalität dieses ersten Trojaners, den wir da hatten, auch noch das Bildschirmfoto machen umfasste. Also nicht wirklich Bildschirmfoto, das ist kein Screenshot im eigentlichen Saison, sondern ein sogenannter Application-Shot, also das Fenster des Programmes. Wurde in ein paar Sekunden Abständen gefotografiert und kamen so einige zehntausend Fotos zusammen. Das ist ohnehin rechtswidrig, auch unstreitig rechtswidrig, wenn man natürlich damit auch in hat, da fast die keine Kommunikation sind. Aber politisch war es für uns deutlich noch wichtiger zeigen zu können, dass ein Nachladen von bliebigen Modulen auch möglich ist. Und da ist es eigentlich dann letztlich auch egal, welches Programm man zur Ausführung bringt auf diesem Windows. Und das kann eben auch nicht nur derjenige steuert, diesen Trojaner, also jetzt mal in diesem Fall eben die Beamten, die Ermittler, sondern wir konnten auch noch zeigen, dass es so schlecht implementiert, dass es auch Dritte können. Dafür haben wir jetzt diesen sogenannten, wie soll man sagen, gegen Trojaner, fake Trojaner gebaut, um zeigen zu können, dass auch Dritte sich dann auf diesem System da verlustigen können und auch Code zur Ausführung bringen können.
Also ich halte fest, mein Rechner wird bei der Zollkontrolle kurz beschlagt haben. Ich habe dann einen Staatstrojaner auf meinem Rechner und dann können beliebige dritte Personen, die einfach fit genug sind, auf meinen Rechner zu greifen, über eine Sicherheitslücke in diesem Staatstrojaner.
Das war ja schlechte Implementierung eigentlich.
Was genau heißt das? Könnt ihr noch so ein bisschen genauer ausführen? Gibt es da irgendwie sowas wie haben...
Ja, normalerweise macht man da halt wirklich Verschlüsselungen und authentifiziert sich sauber und guckt halt wirklich, dass man das zumindest auf ein Niveau hebt, was irgendwo in Richtung Online-Banking geht und nicht irgendwas, was unterhalb von einer Online-Dating-Seite, von der Sicherheit her ist.
Könnten wir so eine Liste mal kurz abgehen? Also Online-Banking ist auf jeden Fall sicherer als der Staatstrojaner. Wie sieht es mit Facebook aus?
Facebook?
Sicherer als der Staatstrojaner oder nicht?
Da fragen wir mal Johnny.
Ja, ich bin noch da.
Ist Facebook sicherer als unser Staatstrojaner? Ich finde die Frage bizarr.
Ich finde, es kommt drauf an, wie man es interpretieren möchte. Aber wenn muss ich so die Authentifizierungsmechanismen von Facebook anbaut? Dann durchaus. Sie haben technisch einiges besser gemacht.
Ja, das stimmt. Sie haben auch übrigens keinen AES-Schlüssel im sogenannten ECB-Mode, der sich nicht ändert. Na ja, wenn man wirklich in jede technische Detail...
Nicht jedes, aber zumindest grob erklären, was es bedeutet.
Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten, bestimmte Kryptographie zu implementieren. Da gibt es bessere und da gibt es schlechtere.
Sie haben ein symmetrisches Verfahren, was eigentlich auch ein Standardverfahren ist, AES, genommen. Das ist erstmal nicht verkehrt. Aber dann kann man natürlich in verschiedenen Arten implementieren. Und Sie haben diesen sogenannten ECB-Modus gewählt. Und hier kann man eigentlich nicht davon reden, dass das Stand der Technik ist. Denn zusätzlich haben Sie auch noch in allen Versionen, die wir bisher gesehen haben, den identischen AES-Key. Also der ist der gleiche genommen. Ja, in der neuen...
Gibt es unterschiedliche Schlüsse mit der schlechten Kryptographie?
Genau, also was am 10. Oktober Digitas behauptet ging bei seinen Behördenkunden, ist, dass sie jetzt dann auch veränderte AES-Keys ausliefern. Aber bisher konnten wir die noch nicht entdecken.
Okay, also das ist ja das, worum man würde sagen, wenn man von seinem Haus über ein Passwort aufgeklärt wird, dann sagt der immer, bitte für jeden Service, für jede Gelegenheit ein unterschiedliches Passwort benutzen. Genau das haben Sie nicht gemacht.
Sie haben es aber in Zukunft jetzt bald, bald. Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Version 4, die dann demnächst rauskommt. Egal. Genau so. Johnny, hast du noch Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Ich hatte eigentlich immer noch so eine Antwort erwartet. Gehofft, ob ihr jetzt wisst, was genau mit diesem Explorer los ist, aber...
Was ist denn genau, was du wissen willst? Die wird sicherlich klar sein, dass die Frage, ob der tatsächlich ausgeführt wurde, nur sehr schwer anhand so einer Analyse zu machen ist. Du kannst schlecht hingehen, dir die binäre Seite ansehen und sagen, was zur Ausführung gekommen sein könnte, in dem speziellen Fall, wo es eingesetzt wurde. Wir wissen natürlich, dass die war schon vorgesehen. Das ist ja so ein modular zusammengesetzter Ding. Denn die Liste der Programme, die dort drin war, ist ja nicht ohne Grund drin. Aber das heißt natürlich noch nicht, dass wir auch sagen können, dass es wirklich in diesem Fall auch zum Einsatz kam.
Das ist schwierig.
Das ist auch der Kritikpunkt. Man kann im Nachhinein nicht sinnvoll feststellen, was passiert ist. Und auch diese Hochladefunktion könnte man theoretisch dazu benutzen, eine Software hochzuladen, die auf dem Rechner Beweise hinterlegt, die man dann nachher irgendwie als Beweis selbst wieder findet. Das ist im Wesentlichen unser Kritikpunkt. Kritikpunkt auch, dass das eben problemlos möglich ist, das zu machen. Aber um noch mal ein Politiker zu zitieren, Herr Uhl hat gesagt, dass das ja glücklicherweise nicht bei 81 Millionen unserer Bundesbürger passiert, sondern nur bei ein paar.
Ich würde kurz sagen, weil es jetzt gerade auch gleich um elf ist, zusammenfassen, also wenn es bei dem Stand, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht verboten hat, dass man Software einnutzt, die mehr kann als nur den Autostream einer Telekommunikation abzulegen.
Also bei der Quarantäkerö?
Bei der Quarantäkerö. Wir haben außerdem festgestellt, es gibt so eine Software, die das kann, die möglicherweise vom Staat kommt. Wie kommt die? Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Hast du ernsthaft Zweifel daran?
Nein. Wenn wir das kennen, das kennen wir einfach hier nach.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich frag euch heute Sendung immer, empfehlt mal Creative Commons Musik, die wir spielen können im Chaos Radio, weil wir auch eine kleine Pause brauchen. Rune Burtles ist das und der Song trägt den schönen Namen Pandoras Fika. Was ihr sozusagen nicht wisst, ist, dass Fika einfach auf Schwedisch Tasche heißt und dass man sich diesen Song einfach runterladen kann. Wir sind hier im Chaos Radio Folge 173. Es geht um den Staatstrojaner und wir haben gerade festgestellt, was das ist, wie der zum Chaos Computer Club gekommen ist und dass er Dinge tut, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich verboten hat. Kurz zusammenfasst könnte man sagen, der Staatstrojaner ist ein Skandal.
Eine Spionage-Software, die auch noch schlimme Qualitätsfehler hat.
Das kommt noch dazu. Das Schöne ist ja immer dann die Reaktion der Politik. Es war also der 8. Oktober und ich habe gesagt, so guckt mal Leute, wir haben einen Staatstrojaner. Was ist dann passiert?
Na ja, es gab ja die Zusammenarbeit mit der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung, die natürlich auch nochmal mehr Leute als unsere Tech-Community auf das Problem aufmerksam gemacht hat. Wir haben natürlich auch vorab versucht, mit verschiedenen Verlagen und natürlich mit Nachrichtenagenturen zusammenzuarbeiten, um eben möglichst breit klar zu machen, was das Problem da ist und dass wir da wirklich auch auf einen politischen Skandal gestoßen sind. Und wir haben natürlich auch versucht, in unserer eigenen Pressemitteilung und in dem kleinen Film, den wir dann gemacht haben, klar zu machen, also deutlich zu machen, auch für eine breite Masse, die jetzt nicht irgendwie Ahnung von Technik haben, was hier eigentlich das Problem ist. Und zum anderen gab es noch den Report. Also wir haben ja noch mal einen kleinteiligeren technischen Report geschrieben, um auch ein bisschen Mithilfe aus der Community zu kriegen. Und das ist ja auch eigentlich passiert.
Den Leuten, die jetzt den Source in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung gesehen haben, die sich fragen, möchte ich jetzt doch noch mal genauer sehen, auch noch mal genauer zu erklären, worum es da eigentlich geht und in einzelnen Schritten was da gelaufen ist und warum und wie und überhaupt.
Letztlich ist ja die einzige Art, wie der Chaos Computer Club mit der Öffentlichkeit interagiert. Wir müssen eine Öffentlichkeit herstellen, wenn wir Probleme sehen. Und hier hat offenkundig ganz gut funktioniert.
Was war denn die erste Reaktion aus der Politik, die euch erreicht hat?
Na, die ist ja eigentlich ein bisschen vorher passiert. Denn wir hatten ja 36 Stunden, bevor wir es veröffentlicht haben, einen Emissär zum Bundesinnenministerium geschickt, weil wir natürlich eine gewisse Vorwarnzeit den Behörden geben wollten. Denn wir wollten uns natürlich jetzt auch nicht irgendwie in laufende Ermittlungsverfahren und so weiter irgendwie einklinken und haben eben...
Man muss denen ja schon noch die Gelegenheit geben, über die Hochladefunktion eine aktualisierte Variante ein, das funktioniert.
Naja, also auch das ist natürlich eigentlich auch ziemlich unangenehm.
Es gebietet die Fernseher einfach mal Bescheid zu sagen, wenn man auf so was gestoßen ist und das wirklich so katastrophal ausgefallen ist. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie sich vorher so hundertprozentig darüber im Klaren waren, was sie da tun. Aber wenn jemand so was sehenden Auges tut, dann muss man doch wissen, dass das einem irgendwann auf den Fuß fällt.
Jetzt habt ihr also angeguckt, habt ihr gesagt, so pass mal auf Leute, wir haben einen Staatstrojaner und in x Stunden gehen wir damit an die Öffentlichkeit. Haben die dann erst mal gesagt, so wir wissen gar nicht wovon ihr redet? Oder wie war die Reaktion?
Naja, es ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass der Staat Rechner infiltriert. Eher geheim war, welche staatlichen Behörden machen das? Wir haben ja eine Menge, wir haben ein Bundeskriminalamt, wir haben die Landeskriminalämter, wir haben ein Bezollkriminalamt, wir haben die Bundespolizei, wir haben natürlich aber auch die Geheimdienste, das heißt BND, aber auch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und die ganzen Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz. Es war ja gar nicht klar, zu wem gehört eigentlich dieser Trojaner und wer hat da eigentlich wem welche Amtshilfe gegeben. Also es kam dann auch so eine merkwürdige Situation zustande, dass die ganze politische Sphäre, ob im Bund oder in den Ländern, sich eigentlich sehr uninformiert zeigten und offenbar gar nicht wussten, was in ihren Behörden läuft. Bis heute.
Erstmal das Fingergezeichen, ja bei uns nicht, aber bestimmt da, also keine Ahnung.
Das hat ja eine Weile gedauert, ja. Also eh dann auch der Herrmann, der Landesinnenminister von Bayern, dann rausrückte, ja also das ist jetzt hier erstmal ein Bayerischer Trojaner, sieht so aus, aber irgendwie hatte Zeugkriminalamtball auch die Finger drin, denn die haben dabei geholfen. Also das ist ja alles noch so ein bisschen ungeklärt. Es ist schließlich auch eine politische Forderung von uns, wir wollen jetzt mal endlich die Daten auf dem Tisch haben. Aber nicht immer diese Gewinseln und diese Halbwahrheiten, die man jetzt hört.
Der Daniel hat angerufen, das könnte man übrigens auch machen, 0331-70-97-1-0 ist die Nummer und möchte genau etwas zum politischen Umgang mit dieser Debatte sagen. Hallo Daniel.
Ja hallo. Ja, schön, dass das Thema auch mal zur Politik kommt, nicht, dass ich die Technik uninteressant finde, aber ich finde halt, dass die ganze Diskussion auch in der Öffentlichkeit ist fast schon ein bisschen zu sehr auf den technischen Aspekt beschränkt. Ich meine, als Bürger freue ich mich ja fast schon, dass das so schlecht implementiert wurde.
Wie siehst du das eigentlich? Warum haben die so unglaublich dilettiert, also einmal technisch, aber vor allen Dingen auch jetzt in der politischen Antwort?
Ich bin bei Politikern immer eher der Ansicht, man sollte Böses vermuten, auch wenn Unwissenheit vielleicht deine Erklärung wäre. Aber ich finde es halt entsetzlich vor allen Dingen, jetzt wo es rausgekommen ist, was dieser Trojaner alles konnte. Und wie er dann damit umgegangen wurde. Wir hatten da zwar erstmal eine große Bundestagsdebatte.
Hast du die angeguckt?
Nein, ich musste leider auch Zeit dazu. Aber drinnen hat man hinterher auch gehört, die Opposition hat natürlich ordentlich auf den Tisch geschlagen, aber im Grunde genommen ist dann beim einmal auf den Tisch geschlagen geblieben. Wir haben hier einen Bundesinnenminister, der im Wesentlichen gesagt hat, ja, die Gerichte und wir sprechen hier von einem rechtkräftigen Urteil, das die Staatsregierung in Bayern auch nicht angefochten hat. Ja, die Gerichte haben eine andere Meinung als die Regierung, aber das ist ja egal.
Also du findest, dass ja man ignoriert, was die deutsche Rechtsprechung sagt, aber natürlich auch das Urteil aus Karlsruhe sagt.
Genau, wenn wir einen bundesinnenminister haben, der in der Öffentlichkeit in einem Interview mit der Hochserienzeitung auch noch praktisch sagt, ja im Rechtsbuch durch die Behörden ist doch ganz in Ordnung, das müssen wir halt tun.
Also du findest den politischen Skandal dahinter und destört, dass die anderen gar nicht so richtig darauf eingehen.
Ja, der FDP hat sich nur ganz vereinzelt an der Hochschrittsforderung gehört. Ich glaube, ich habe nur eine oder zwei gehört. FDP gab mir glaube ich eine, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Was ist denn in deiner Meinung nach die Konsequenz? Findest du?
Dass das ein Minister ungestraft lagen kann und da kein Aufschreiwislang ist. Das macht irgendwie nichts Gutes über unsere politische Kultur aus.
Also du findest auch der Ersatz weg?
Auf jeden Fall.
Okay, und würdest du dir aber vorher noch von ihm wünschen, dass er draufklärt?
Vielleicht hat er einfach keine Ahnung, weil ich auch, zumindest aber technisch nebene, durchaus glaube, müssten wir eigentlich jetzt spätestens Konsequenzen ziehen. Wurden ja auch in dem Augenblick gemacht, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, wir setzen das erstmal nicht mehr ein. Weil der ganze Umgang dafür ist eigentlich, mindestens die Innenminister von Bund und Bayern müssten eigentlich weg. Im Grunde genommen eigentlich alle Innenminister von Ländern, die sie eingesetzt haben. Das wäre eine lustige Innenministerkonferenz dann das nächste Mal, die wäre sehr leer.
Weil diesen Einsatzstopp betrifft, da ist er wieder zurückgerudert übrigens. Ja, war sein Bayerischer Amtskollege, der eben schon besagte Herrmann, der hat ja irgendwie diesem Stopp dann nicht zustimmen wollen, das heißt, es gibt keinen bundes- oder landesweiten Stopp dieser Software.
Ja gut, inzwischen haben wir ja auch eine neue Version, das heißt, wenn wir gesagt hätten, wir stoppen den Einsatz, nehmen wir einfach die andere Version, da bin ich auch Informatiker genug, um sowas genau zu verstehen.
Dann würdest du eigentlich finden, dass, mal angenommen, also er kann sich echt nicht halten in diesem Job, findest du das sein Nachfolger oder wie sollte er das angehen in Bezug auf die Transparenz, also was würdest du fordern? Von seinem Nachfolger jetzt?
Vom Nachfolger, das ist natürlich die wichtigste Forderung für zukünftige Einsätze einer, ich sag mal derartigen Software, um das mögliche beizufassen, was ihr auch schon gefordert habt jetzt hier im Radio und auch vorher schon, dass diese Transparenzkriterien erfüllt sein müssen, das heißt, wer muss den einsetzenden Behörden wirklich im Quellcode vorliegen und selbst übersetzen und so weiter und die müssen Leute haben, die das von Verstehen rein technisch gesehen, sodass man zumindest sichergehen kann, dass die Behörden wissen, was sie tun. Nur, ihr habt es jetzt angesprochen, von wegen Nachweisen auf eine Software, das irgendetwas nicht kann, ist schwer bis unmöglich. Von daher sehe ich eigentlich einen verfassungskonformen und rechtmäßigen Einsatz eines Trojaners generell sehr kritisch und gerade wenn es nur um Telekommunikationsüberwachung geht, fragt man mal Skype oder wem auch immer an, die geben einem von den Mitschnitten. Da braucht man halt gar nicht die Computer zu infiltrieren.
Okay, dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch mal gucken, ist denn so was wie ein Staatstrojaner überhaupt möglich, um diesem Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil zu entsprechen. Bevor wir dazu kommen, sprechen wir jetzt noch mit Kai. Vielen Dank erst mal Daniel, der eine Frage oder eine Meinung zur Analyse-Darstellung durch den CCC hat. Hallo Kai.
Hallo, ganz grundsätzlich erstmal vielen, vielen Dank für die Arbeit des CCC. Also das kann man gar nicht hoch genug schätzen.
Da freuen wir uns.
Nein, also das ist wirklich Wahnsinn.
Hat auch Spaß gemacht übrigens.
Im Nachhinein betrachtet hätte man gerne mitgemacht, wenn man es gewusst hätte aufeinander.
Du kannst dich noch beteiligen, also die IDDBs liegen da, tue dir keinen Zwang.
Ja, was ich jetzt noch in Anschluss an den Vorredner sagen wollte, bei den Forderungen, die wir stellen müssen, da muss ganz klar sein, dass wir uns nicht in Kleinteiligkeit skaloppieren. Wir müssen ganz klar fordern, Trojaner auf Privatrechnern durch den Staat darf es nicht geben. Schluss, Aus, Ende, Punkt, Final.
Da können wir uns durchaus auch anschließen, so ist nicht.
Nein, also warum, da stellt sich einfach nicht die Frage. Nachher kann ich fast nie nachweisen, bis nie nachweisen, dass da nicht sonst noch was gelaufen ist. Also wenn ich beim Richter hinterlege, Version A auf dem Rechner war, Version B, die Überprüfung in der Forensik geschieht auch durchs LKA. Also im Zweifel zwei, wenn da sich Leute kurzschließen. Also man könnte es nicht ausschließen, Gerichtsfest. Meiner Ansicht nach, dass da nichts gelaufen ist, wo dann die eine Stelle die andere Stelle schützt oder deckt oder wie auch immer.
Ich muss aber sagen, in der Argumentation kriegst du spätestens ein Problem, wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt so, naja gut, technisch gesehen magst du Recht haben, aber wenn du das unterstellst, dann unterstellst du den Behörden ja bei jedem Ermittlungsverfahren, dass sie böswillig sind. Das würde dann auch heißen, irgendwie Spuren am Tatort werden gefälscht, Drogen werden untergeschoben. Also das kannst du ja sozusagen in jedem Ermittlungsverfahren an jeden Stellen...
Nee, nee, nee, nicht wirklich. Ein normales Ermittlungsverfahren hat immer, immer erstens, also wenn am Tatort da bin, ist nicht nur ein Polizist oder so, der das in seinem Stimmenkämmerlein macht und der auch die fachliche Kompetenz womöglich dann am Ende hat, das zu tun, sondern da sind mehrere Leute parallel. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass alle irgendwie, naja, sagen, Rechtsstaat ist mir egal, ich will meine Verurteilung am Ende sehen, ist relativ gering. Außerdem, wie gesagt, dem einzelnen Polizisten kann man bestimmt vertrauen. Die Gefahr kommt immer dann, wenn sich der Polizist hinter der Behörde verstecken kann und sagen kann, bei euch ja nicht. Ja, oder dem Hersteller in dem Fall. Und das Problem ist, dass so eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, TKÜ, Quellen-TKÜ oder wie es auch immer beschönigt wird, dann genannt wird, das ist ja relativ geheim und verdeckt. Das ist ja keine offene Maßnahme.
Nein, nicht relativ, es ist total geheim und verdeckt. Ja, jetzt im Nachhinein nicht mehr, aber...
Nein, aber ich unterstelle auch mal, dass potenziell nicht alle kriminellen Unbedarf sind technisch und womöglich so was naken können.
Bisher kennen wir keinen Fall, wo der Verdächtige selber bemerkt hatte, während der Ermittlung.
Das ist doch keine Fälle, die vor Gericht kommen.
Aber die, die da bisher gelaufen sind, das war auch alles nichts, was in irgendeiner Form in der Nähe dessen war, was durch das Gerichtsurteil gedeckt worden wäre. Also das waren jetzt keine Fälle, wo es wirklich um erhebliche Rechtsgüter, um irgendwie Schaden...
Eine schwerste Kriminalität oder Gefahren für den Staat.
Das war...
Das ist aber jetzt auch wieder unterscheiden.
Aber das war doch zu erwarten. Allein deshalb schon... Wenn der CCC oder auch sonst Hacker an sich auftreten, da sollten wir uns echt nicht... Also auf die Details sollten wir uns da nicht einlassen. Das machen dann die Politiker nachher schon von selber. Nein, also ganz klar dieses Klein-Klein und dieses Hin- und Hergezerre, ja geht das oder geht das nicht, das machen dann schon die Politiker und die werden es auch schon weit genug verwässern. Da ist es dann, finde ich, besser, wenn sich der CCC mit einer Verstände oder sonst überhaupt die Leute mit technischem Sachverstand mit einer relativ extremen Position in so einem Fall hinstellen und sagen, ja, also...
Das ist jetzt schon eine Extremposition zu fordern, dass ein Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts eingehalten werden muss. Das muss man mal in der Wahrnehmung irgendwie, dass das als Extremposition durchgeht, dass sich Leute, die es schafft, die Urteil halten.
Nein, aus meiner Sicht ist das keine Extremposition. Aber das Problem ist, wenn man dann schon anfängt zu sagen und die Argumentation aufmacht, na ja, wenn es dann eben halbwegs konform wäre zum Urteil, ging es ja wenigstens nicht, dann steigen sie drauf ein. Und dann kommen diese ganzen Sachen, die Herrmann oder wie sie alle heißen gebracht haben. Ja, aber wir haben es ja nur rechtskonform eingesetzt. Das war der genialste Spin, den ich gesehen habe. Und die Presse ist drauf reingefallen. Also in weiten Teilen abzuschreiben und dann nicht kritisch danebenzuschreiben, ja, ihr hättet das ja gar nicht so einsetzen dürfen.
Ja, aber Kai, die Lesekompetenz, die man dann dem Leser zumutet, okay, der hat jetzt so großen Unsinn geredet, das brauchen wir nicht mehr kommentieren, das wird der Leser selbst verstehen.
Das ist die Feferlogik, oder?
Aber sag mal Kai, glaubst du wirklich, dass man den Einsatz eines wie auch immer gearteten Staatsstrojaners verhindern kann in Zukunft?
Also politisch verhindern?
Politisch verhindern kann man den bestimmt nicht, aber man muss klare Regeln aufstellen, dass das nicht geht. Und wenn das nicht geht, dann muss es auch für alle Verantwortlichen klare Strafen geben. Denn zum Beispiel jetzt, was ich überhaupt nicht in der Diskussion gesehen habe, ist irgendwelche Konsequenzen rechtlicher Natur, die für die jeweiligen...
Rechtsbrecher?
Ja, Rechtsbrecher, ob das jetzt der Polizist ist, der kann sich womöglich am Ende noch darauf raustreten, dass er irgendeinen Befehl bekommen hat. Würde ich womöglich sogar noch akzeptieren wollen, der kleine Polizist am Ende der Befehlskette hat womöglich überhaupt nichts zu entscheiden gehabt, was das angeht. Aber spätestens dann auf politischer Ebene, da muss dann irgendwann was kommen. Also wenn es ein Bruch dessen ist, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist, das muss hochverrat sein, aber das ist es halt irgendwie nicht.
Na gut, aber hochverrat ist vielleicht ein bisschen doller, oder?
Also Polizisten haben sich im Dienst schon an das Grundgesetz zu halten.
Mir geht es aber eigentlich nicht ums Strafrecht. Also ich würde immer eher denken, dass das eine Frage des politischen Anstandes ist und auch der politischen Kultur. Also ich würde da gar nicht mal mit den Paragrafen reiten wollen. Also da geht es um Verantwortung, die jemand übernimmt, wenn über viele Jahre, und das Urteil ist ja ein bisschen älter, ignoriert wird. Ich bin da schon mit dir, also ich kann das schon verstehen, was du sagst.
Ja, muss man es auch aus der Position der Beamten, die da arbeiten, sehen. Wenn die so ein Tool in die Hand gedrückt bekommen und den Auftrag macht damit mal was, das kann ich mir durchaus unangenehmst vorstellen, sowas dann einsetzen zu müssen, wo eben ganz genau, oder ja, die Frage nicht geklärt ist, kann das mehr, kann ich mich da jetzt in irgendeiner Form mit Strafe machen? Mach ich da jetzt Dinge, die irgendwie nicht korrekt sein sind? Kann ich mich hier überhaupt so verhalten, dass es rechtlich einwandfrei ist?
Die Frage ist, ob ein Beamter in der Stelle überhaupt mitkriegt, was er da macht. Ob er da überhaupt klar kriegt, dass er jetzt nicht eine Software anwendet, die ihm an Frauen spricht, sondern dass da irgendwas anderes passiert.
Wir müssen sehen, die Digitask-Firma ist da hingegangen, hat auch eine ordentliche Produktpresentation gemacht. Also was man ja in der Regel als bedienender Beamte kriegt, ist ja erst mal nur eine Oberfläche, mit der man umgeht.
Der Beamte kriegt diese Software und denkt dann so, alles super. Ist ja abgesegnet und revisionssicher protokolliert.
Oh man, das Schlagwort hatten wir noch gar nicht.
Kai auf jeden Fall erst mal vielen Dank. Er sagt, auf jeden Fall extreme Forderungen sind ganz wichtig und jemand zurücktreten sollte auch. Wir haben jetzt noch, bevor wir zur revisionssicheren Protokollierung kommen, den Peter, der eine Frage hat.
Ich würde gerne direkt an Kai anknüpfen und mich ihm auch nochmal anschließen mit dem Dank an den CCC. Ja, es sind eure Pressemeldungen an Punkt 4 eine Forderung, die ich beim ersten Mal fast überlesen hätte und beim zweiten Mal dachte ich, das ist eigentlich ein sehr genialer Punkt.
Du meinst die Infiltration und Beweissicherheit.
Genau, das meine ich so. Als Informatiker wissen wir erstmal, dass es nicht möglich ist, technisch einen Missbrauch einer Software zu verhindern. Auf der rechtlichen Ebene wissen wir, dass man da zwar viel regeln kann, was aber nicht unter allen Umständen immer eingehalten wird oder eingehalten werden kann. Als ich mich dann mit dem Punkt beschäftigt habe, dachte ich, die uns regierenden Sicherheitsbehörden, laut Herrn Muhl haben wir nicht alle gesagt, wir haben das Ding ja nur regelkonform eingesetzt. Wenn es ein Beweismittelverwertungsverbot gäbe, für sämtliche Daten, die nichts mit der direkten Kommunikation zusammenhängen, dann wäre zumindest in einem Verfahren ja auch kein Missbrauch dieser Daten oder Entgegbrauch dieser Daten mehr möglich. Mich würde dann erstmal interessieren, wer da an Ministern oder irgendwelchen Arztchefs nachher sagen würde, nein, das geht ja nicht, weil. Also wir können diese Beweismittel nicht verbieten, weil. Nur dann kämen sie an dem Punkt ja nicht mehr weiter, weil da keine Argumente mehr vorhanden wären. Mich interessiert jetzt vor allen Dingen, ob man wohl diesen Punkt weiter ausbauen könnte. Constanze ist da ja sehr an der Front, politisch.
An der Front?
An der Front, ja. Das war nämlich, was ich heute auch getwittert hatte, ich hab's auch direkt an ihre Adresse gerichtet und gesagt, das wäre eigentlich ihr Punkt jetzt darauf einzusteigen, zu sagen, da machen wir das Ding doch rechtlich wasserdicht. Dann brauchen wir uns darüber schon mal nicht mehr zu streiten.
Ja, also ich kann mehrere Hinweise geben. Also es gab ja mit der Justizministerin auch Gespräche, nachdem wir es veröffentlicht haben, weil sie ja auch technisch sehr großes Interesse hatte. Also auch erstmal zu erfahren, was da eigentlich wirklich technisch geht. Denn offenbar ist es ja auch für sie als Ministerin über die Behörden nur sehr schwer zu erfahren. Zum anderen würde morgen, also ohne dass sie, ich will nicht Werbung machen, aber eine große Zeitung hat morgen ein längeres Interview mit ihr. Also wo sich zwei Leute, unter anderem ich vom CCC, mit ihr zusammengesetzt haben und nochmal darüber gesprochen haben. Nachdem jetzt einfach ja noch viele ochiöstische Fragen offen sind. Sie ist ja nun mal die Bundesjustizministerin. Also wer den morgen lesen will, dem sei vielleicht, da ist nämlich die Frage der Beweislichkeit auch nochmal angesprochen, zu Lektüre empfohlen. Allerdings, letztlich glaube ich, eine Ministerin hat sicherlich ein gut Gespür dafür, was ist eigentlich wirklich machbar. Und man muss natürlich sehen, welche Extrempositionen sich da letztlich gegenüberstehen. Nämlich die Frage, Leute die sagen, es gibt Kommunikationen, wir müssen die abhören. Das ist ja wirklich so die Friedrich Nummer auch, die im Interview sagt, das Entscheidende ist, wir können abhören, anderen ist es erstmal egal. Und wenn man dann mit solchen Argumenten kommt wie, ja aber was ist denn mit Beweissicherheit, dann gerät man in auch schwierige rechtliche Fragen. Denn auch heute können natürlich unrechtmäßig erlangte Beweise verwendet werden, unter bestimmten Umständen. Es gibt also nicht ein generelles Verbot, der sozusagen, die Engländer sagen Fruit of a Poison Tree, also dass man eben auf dem verbotenen Wege etwas erlangt hat. Man kann das in Deutschland teilweise machen. Und das ist ein schwieriges juristisches Minenfeld. Also empfehle die Lektüre dann morgen. Man merkt ja auch, dass die Justizministerin durchaus ein bisschen rumeiert. Aber aus unserer technischen Sicht ist das eigentlich vollkommen klar. Wir wünschen uns, dass wenn sie infiltrieren, die Beweise davon nicht erlangt werden können. Das hieße aber in der Konsequenz, dass es eine Infiltration überhaupt nur noch für die Online-Gesuchung geben darf. Und dann ja eben unter den besonders...
Für die Quellentickerübe geben darf.
Ja, für die Quellentickerübe. Also aus meiner Sicht müsste die für das Strafverfahren weg. Denn das ist beweislich ja nicht zu erlangen. Also mag ja sein, dass ich da irgendwie zu technisch denke und zu wenig juristisch, aber... Also ich kenne mit der Argumentation, dass man eben, es geht technisch und wir müssen unbedingt abhören, wir müssen überhaupt nichts anfangen, wenn ich mir die technischen Realitäten ansehe und feststelle, eigentlich ist es nicht sicher zu machen, dass man sagen kann, ich habe hier ein beweisfestes, ja zum Beispiel, Datei, die ich eben im Gerichtshofverfahren später auch verwenden kann. Also bei uns haben eben auch Leute, gegen die ermittelt wird, viele Rechte. Und die sollte man dann genauso gut stärken wie die Rechte der Ermittler, die ja sehr viel gestärkt wurden in den letzten Jahren.
Jetzt ist eine Frage, die im Blog aufgetaucht ist auch, wenn man genau bei dieser Diskussion eine Frage stellt, dann sagt man halt sowas und dann sagen andere Leute, ja, aber weißt du eigentlich, ich vertraue dem Staat. Es ist doch gut, dass er die Verbrecher fängt und dann muss er halt auch diese Mittel zu einsetzen. Und das ist schon irgendwie okay. Gibt es da Gegenargumente?
Wir fragen einfach mal Peter, wo er schon da ist. Vertraust du da?
Ich neige immer wieder dazu, bis ich dann an irgendeinem Punkt wieder sehe, dass das Vertrauen vielleicht doch ein Stück zu weit ging. Und gerade dieser Staatstrojaner ist jetzt wieder so ein Punkt. Ich beschäftige mich ja auch schon seit 2007 etwa intensiv mit dem Thema und habe viele Diskussionen geführt an allen möglichen Orten mit allen möglichen Leuten. Und dachte dann, okay, ich mache jetzt irgendwann mal den Punkt. Ich nehme all das, was uns versichert wird von der Politik und nehme das mal als gegeben. Es wird gesagt, in welchen Grenzen es eingesetzt wird. Wir haben zwischendurch gehört, dass es nur ein- oder zweimal überhaupt eingesetzt wurde.
Angeblich, aber nun ganz sicher nicht, stimmt bei dir nun wissen?
Ja, genau so. Und dann kommt der Punkt, wo wir dann plötzlich wieder erfahren, aha, es läuft offensichtlich doch anders. Das heißt, wir sind eigentlich gezwungen, da ständig den Druck aufrechtzuerhalten und ständig zu misstrauen. Wir sind gezwungen zu misstrauen, auch wenn wir vertrauen möchten.
Aber ist es nicht unsere Aufgabe als Bürger, wenn wir nicht scharfer sein sollen, sondern mündige Bürger? Ist es sowieso unsere Aufgabe, denen immer wieder auf die Finger zu gucken?
Das ist in dem Moment, wo wir uns politisch engagieren und aufmerksam sind, natürlich. Nur geht das ja für eine sehr große Masse eben nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Unterhaltung, die ihr gerade führt, die ist sozusagen, also Leute, die derselben Meinung sind, bekräftigen sich darüber. Wenn jetzt aber jemand ankommt und sagt, was willst du denn machen gegen die Terroristen oder gegen die bösen Schwerfabriken?
Was sagt man denen dann? Ich interessiere mich nicht für Politik.
Entschuldigung, hier war kein Terrorismus, hier war ein Kaufmann, der Medikamente exportiert und einen Bodybuilder, der mit Anabolika gehandelt hat.
Auch das ist verfliegt gekurnt gekommen, bisher in der Diskussion, dass es nie um Terroristen und schwere Kriminalität ging.
Der Punkt ist halt, man sollte sich nicht einfacher Bürger darum kümmern müssen, dass die Leute da sich gesetzeskonform verhalten.
Da werden wir nicht mehr dran vorbeikommen.
Das ist das Traurige, da sollte es eigentlich Kontrollinstanzen geben, die automatisch das sicherstellen und das scheint da nicht der Fall zu sein.
Hier ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr.
Die LKAs haben sich ja sogar den Einsatz gegenseitig abgenickt und gesagt, die Software ist okay, haben wir uns auch angeguckt. Das war ja sogar eine Forderung, dass das extern noch mal angeschaut werden sollte, wenn so etwas eingesetzt wird. Und extern sah dann für die aus. Ja, das hat aber das LKAs im anderen Bundesland sich für uns angeguckt.
Moment, ich will noch mal einen Aspekt ansprechen, der scheint mir noch mal wichtig. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass hier nur so ein simpler Rechtsbruch passiert ist. Sondern was wir hier blicken, finde ich eigentlich einen größeren Skandal. Ich hatte das vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet. Das Urteil ist vom Februar 2008, was wirklich viel Zeit ist, die vergangen ist. Und dieses Urteil ist an Klarheit eigentlich nicht missverstehend. Das kann sich jeder ansehen. Wenn die Quellentheke betrifft, ist das eindeutig und klar. Und auch die Unzulässigkeit bestimmter Funktionalitäten, zum Beispiel eben den Update- und Nachladefunktionen, aber natürlich auch die Bildschirmfotos, insbesondere die sind schon längst festgestellt. Es gibt das Urteil Auslandshut, das werden viele jetzt kennen. Es gibt aber auch juristische Literatur. Ich darf zum Beispiel verweisen auf mehrere Texte von Ulf Bührmeier, von Matthias Becker, also angesehener Verfassungsjuristen oder auch jetzt kürzlich von Frank Braun. Es ist ja jetzt schon klar, dass hätte längst eine genaue Regelung geschaffen werden müssen, weil das im Urteil ja drin steht. Und sie nehmen aber einfach den 100a, der Strafprozessordnung, also so eine Art Auffangparagraph für alle möglichen Telekommunikationsüberwachungen. Nach 100a erlaubt die Telekommunikationsüberwachung für sehr, sehr viele Fälle für so einen Straftatenkatalog. Man hätte aber eigentlich eine viel konkretere Lösung finden müssen, denn das steht bereits im Urteil seit Jahren. Deshalb ärgert mich insbesondere diese Ignoranz gegen die Urteile und dass man überhaupt nicht auf die Idee kommt, auch nur einen Mühe hinter dem Urteil zurück zu bleiben und nach so einer Klatsche aus Karlsruhe mal nachzudenken. Okay, wie können wir denn eine balancierte Lösung finden? Wir wollen einen Verbrecher fangen, ja klar, aber wie kann eine Lösung aussehen, die nicht genau diese Verfassungsgrenze aus Karlsruhe umsetzt, sondern einfach überlegt, wo eine sinnvolle Balance sein kann, die nicht immer nur die Sicherheitsbehörden in den Vordergrund schiebt? Und da scheint mir der eigentliche Skandal, den wir uns auch gewöhnt haben.
Das ist tatsächlich sozusagen eine Frage, über die würde ich dann gerne nochmal genau darüber sprechen. Was ich auch in der Diskussion gesehen habe, ist, es geht hier um einen sozusagen Bruch eines Verfassungsgerichtsentscheidens, einer Verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung. Aber eigentlich ist es auch bei den Leuten, die das entdeckt haben und die Leute, die auf der Seite dieser Aktivisten sind, ist eher so, naja, das ist schlimm, aber wir wussten es ja immer. Irgendwie ein bisschen komisch. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio Folge 173, wo es um den Staatstrojaner geht, wo wir schon darüber gesprochen haben, wie der aussieht, was der so kann, warum er das nicht können darf und wie die politische Reaktion darauf ist. Haben wir noch was wichtiges vergessen?
Ja, es gibt noch einen schönen Hinweis, nämlich von Jens Kubizier. Der hat uns im Twitter gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass es eine sehr schöne Darstellung von Heise gibt. Wenn man mal wissen will, also wie eben dieser ECB-Modus bei den Verschlüsselungskies nix sagt, da kann sich mal so eine grafische Darstellung......von dem Algorithmus... Und wer die finden will, der kann einfach in Niblas Twitter-Account klicken oder in Kubizier. Und da findet man diesen Link zu dieser schönen Grafik. Ich finde die sehr gelungen, die zeigt das sehr schön.
Wunderbar, jetzt ist ja im Laufe dieser ganzen Diskussion auch gefordert worden. Ich möchte mal vorgreifen, dass es ein Inter-Minister geben soll.
Meint ihr, das würde was helfen? Ja, heute haben wir ja schon die ganze Zeit gewartet, dass der BDK, der ist ja so eine Art Lobbyverband, kann man schon fast sagen, der Kriminal, sich mal äußert. Jetzt sind die mit dem Reset-Knopf für das Internet, die haben eine tolle Forderung und heute war wieder der Bundesinternetminister, der allerdings schon öfter mal kam. Und wir warten ja noch auf Vorschläge.
Wer das da machen soll.
Ja, es ist ja auch sehr lustig, dass Sie damit den Innenminister in gewisser Weise schon als ledig betrachten. Und dann müssen wir mal einen hinstellen, der was von Internet versteht. Finde ich eigentlich eine interessante Herangehensweise. Aber natürlich hat der BDK gleichzeitig gesagt, natürlich müssen wir Rechner infiltrieren, als sei Gott gegeben.
Das ist natürlich total wichtig. Ich habe noch so ein paar Detailfragen, die...
Herr Uhlsinn, das neue Schlagwort. Wer ist Herr Uhl eigentlich noch mal genauer erklärt, der ist langjähriger Innenexperte und auch ist doch im Innenausschuss und gehört zum Deutschen Bundestag und zur Fraktion der Union.
Es gibt noch ein paar Fragen, die im Laufe der Sendung bei mir hängen geblieben sind. Das eine ist revisionssichere Protokollierung. Es gab ja eine Aktuelle Stunde im Bundestag, da wurde also häufig darüber gesprochen, so okay, wie, liebes BKA, da war irgendwie ein Sprecher vom Innenministerium, wie wird denn festgestellt, ob der Trojaner das kann, was er ist? Und da kam die interessante Vorstellung, okay, da werden Tests im Labor gemacht, man spannt die Software in so eine Art Schraubstock ein und hämmert dann drauf rum. Und da wurde immer revisionssichere Protokollierung gesagt. Und ich hab dann mal auf Twitter gefragt, ob mir einer erklären kann, was das ist, und bekam die Antwort, ich hab Beamtentum studiert und es gibt ein Buch dazu, was du lesen könntest, aber das geht nicht so kurz. Wisst ihr, was das ist, revisionssichere Protokollierung?
Man kann es schon ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Übrigens, also dieser Sprecher im Bundestag, das war der Staatssekretär Ole Schröder, das war nicht irgendein Sprecher. Aber egal. Tatsächlich, in dem Zusammenhang fiel diese revisionssichere Protokollierung ziemlich das erste Mal. Also auch so ein bisschen, dass es in die Öffentlichkeit kam. Was man damit meint, ist revisionssicher im technischen und juristischen Sinne. Das heißt, eine Information wird so aufgezeichnet, zum Beispiel auf einem Medium, was man nur einmal beschreiben kann, oder eben auch tatsächlich ausdrucken geht durchaus, und zwar in einer sicheren Umgebung, sodass man weiß, dass Dritte auf diese Umgebung Software-Hardware-mäßig keinen Zugriff haben. Das nennt man dann revisionssicher. Auch im Sinne von Gerichtsfest könnte man das übersetzen, sodass die ganze Prozedur in der Aufzeichnung Schritt für Schritt nachvorziehbar ist und nicht manipuliert werden kann.
Vor allem im Nachhinein nicht mehr verändert werden kann, also nicht mehr revidiert werden kann, daher revisionssicher.
Das würde aber für den Trojaner-Einsatz bedeuten, das müsste sagen, von Anfang an, also vom ersten Einsatz bis zum Ende passieren. Wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, ist das doch aber nicht möglich.
Na, nimm mal, erklärt mal, wie man das macht. Man könnte das theoretisch schon machen, allerdings kann man nicht beweisen, dass man sich in der Zwischenzeit mit diesem Rechner verbunden hat und da Dinge hinterlegt hat. Weil eben, wie wir nachgewiesen haben, dass jederzeit möglich ist, dass man, wenn man das Protokoll kennt, sich mit diesem Rechner verbinden kann und da genau die Dinge tun kann, die auch der Beamte vor seiner Workstation tut. Von daher kann da so viel revisionssicher geschehen auf der Workstation, die der Beamte da vor sich stehen hat. Solange Dritte daran rummanipulieren können und die Software so schlecht ist, dass sich noch nicht mal dagegen geschützt wird, ja, ist das cool aus.
Also sagen, revisionssicher protokolliert kann werden, ist eine Phrase, eine politische Phrase, die eigentlich mit den technischen Realitäten nicht zusammengeht. Ich möchte nochmal, ist irgendwie von dem Sprechzettel in den Mikrofon gekommen.
Ich möchte nochmal kurz fragen, was der Beamte, der an dem Trojaner sitzt, könnte man möglicherweise, sage ich jetzt mal, revisionssicher protokollieren, aber was andere Leute mit derselben Software machen nicht, ist es nicht generell überhaupt ein Problem, wenn man einen Rechner überwacht, dass man gar nicht weiß, ob jetzt die Eingabe, die man da gerade mitliest, von dem Typen kommt, der vor dem Rechner sitzt, oder ob das irgendjemand fernsteuert?
Richtig, darum haben wir ja diesen Fake-Trojaner vorgestellt, der eben irgendwelche Sachen zurückliefert und nicht das, was eingegeben wird. Und da kann natürlich statt einem Foto von Schäuble auf dem Rückkanal ein Fensterinhalt, der unverdächtig ist, zurückgeschickt werden. Also es muss nicht unbedingt nur Katzenbilder zurückkommen, sondern es kann auch was Geschicktes zurückkommen, wo man dann eben nicht weiß, ob das jetzt wirklich echt ist oder nicht echt ist.
Wir haben auch ein bisschen darauf verwiesen, über was wir hier eigentlich reden. Wir müssen ja auch manchmal über Wirtschaftspionage und dergleichen nachdenken. Wir haben ja nur Fälle aus dem Bereich des Zollkriminalamts. Hier muss man auch überlegen, ob eventuelle Konkurrenten Interesse hätten, Daten zu platzieren oder manipulieren. Man kann ja auch jemanden beschuldigen wollen. Und erst recht, wenn man vielleicht über Verfahren redet im Bereich der organisierten Kriminalität, wo man mit ernsthafter Gegenwehr auch technischer zu rechnen hat. Da kann man nicht mit so einem Lulli-Programm kommen, von Dilettanten programmiert. Da muss man sich doch wirklich fragen, gegen wen die da spielen wollen. Wir haben ja auch Fälle jetzt erfahren, fand ich eine unglaubliche Dreistigkeit, wo sie nicht mal geschafft haben, ein Ding zu platzieren und teilweise die Festmatte beschädigt haben. All diese Fälle kommen jetzt aus dem Bundesland zusammen. Und ich bin jetzt schon gespannt, was in den fünf, sechs Wochen, wenn die ganzen Anfragen in den Parlamenten und im Bundestag beantwortet werden müssen, was da noch ans Tageslicht kommt. Ich bin auch immer noch entröstet darüber, dass wir immer noch keinen Innenminister haben im Land und im Bund, der doch mal die Fakten auf den Tisch legt. Jetzt immer dieses Gesag ja, da gibt es vielleicht noch andere Firmen, ja welche denn? Wir wollen sie gerne mal hören. Also irgendwie jetzt alle paar Monate mit neuen Trojanern, die wir analysieren, kommen. Also ich finde, das ist einfach eine Bringschuld der Politik. Die haben die Rechte übertreten. Jetzt finde ich, sind sie den Bürgern auch mal schuldig klar, einen Reintisch zu machen, sowieso den Einsatz zu stoppen und ordentliche gesetzliche Grundlagen zu schaffen, die wir debattieren sollten, allesamt. Und offensichtlich ja auch noch innerhalb der Regierungskoalition, da ist ja wenig Einigkeit.
Statt selbstgefährlich zu sagen, ach das Recht, das wird man ja wohl nochmal übertreten können als Politiker.
Also das finde ich, ist tatsächlich auch eine Forderung, die wir laut und deutlich immer wieder sagen sollten. Jetzt müssen die erstmal sagen. Sie haben eh immer nur zugegeben, was wir quasi beweislicher hatten, weil sie auch nicht mehr abstreiten konnten. Diese Taktik finde ich so...
Aber seid ihr von der Öffentlichkeit selber auch ein bisschen frustriert, weil ihr fordert das immer und die Öffentlichkeit...
Wir sind die Öffentlichkeit von der Politik. Wir sind einfach genauso frustriert, wie die Wähler da draußen, die gerade sehen, dass die Politiker da rumeiern und irgendwie...
Naja, aber darauf wollte ich ja gerade hinaus. Der CCC sagt so, okay, Staatstrojaner. Der CCC sagt dann so, okay Leute, das geht so nicht weiter. Und der CCC sagt, was Konz gerade gesagt hat, ihr müsst jetzt mal die Dinge auf den Tisch legen. Und alle anderen stellen sich in Präzision und sagen so, cool, der CCC kümmert sich drum, das ist schon ganz schön krass, was da passiert ist, aber das läuft schon irgendwie. Also ich an eurer Stelle würde denken, die Aufregung könnte auch mal ein bisschen größer sein oder nicht?
Ich würde das so eigentlich nicht unbedingt bestätigen. Das eine ist, wir haben unglaublich viele Zuschriften bekommen. Also solche, die sich damit jetzt technisch weiter befasst haben, aber natürlich auch eine Menge in aller Richtung politische Zuschriften. Wir haben mit allen Parteien eigentlich Kontakt. Wir waren bei der FDP, wir waren bei den Sozialdemokraten, wir haben mit der Linkspartei gesprochen. Also da gibt es durchaus eine Menge Kontakte und wir werden auch mit der Union reden. Also das heißt, der Bedarf an Informationen in der politischen Sphäre ist groß und der Bedarf an Zustimmung so, der jetzt auf uns einprasset, ist auch enorm. Also wir sehen natürlich auch, dass wir damit irgendwie Leute erreicht haben, auch gerade, weil wir zusammen mit der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung gemacht haben, weil wir es jetzt auch ein bisschen übersetzt haben und auch noch aus der englischsprachigen Welt kommt, eine Menge Leute, die uns da helfen wollen, die die Anfragen in allen Landesparlamenten gestellt haben, von ganz verschiedenen Parteien, die auf Abgeordnetenbotsche gefragt haben, die Peter Altmaier zugetwittert haben. Also da heißt der Peter ja Peter Altmaier. Also da gibt es schon eine Menge Protestpotenzial und Empörung und die kommt auch bei uns an. Ich bin da überhaupt nicht, ich habe da keine Angst vor der Zukunft, sondern ich wünsche mir, dass diese Entröstung schlicht politisch genutzt wird. Naja, ich will jetzt nichts über die Piraten sagen. Also ich bin dann gar nicht so pessimistisch, weil ich den Eindruck habe, die Empörung ist echt, die schlägt uns entgegen und da gibt es Leute, die auch sich richtig engagieren. Also ich meine, diese Anfragen in den Parlamenten, die von allen möglichen Fraktionen kommen, die entstehen ja auch erst. Wir müssen die Leute nicht lesen, verstehen. Ich habe Fragenkataloge von 10 bis 50 Fragen, die in den Parlamenten da ankommen. Da will ich erstmal die Antworten hören. Das wird schon nochmal spannend die nächsten Wochen. Wer weiß, man kann auch nie wissen, was wir noch so haben.
Okay, also sagen, aber ich hatte jetzt eher spekuliert in Richtung Demonstrationen und wie man auf die Straße geht.
Ja, ich hätte nüscht dagegen. Also wir haben ja schließlich auch noch dieses große Pferd, diese zwei Meter Pferde, die wir durch die Gegend ziehen können.
Das könnte man doch nochmal einsehen. Ich finde es auch keine schlechte Idee. Ich habe jetzt nochmal eine kleine Detailfrage, die zum Anfang der Geschichte geht. Ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, dass es noch eigentlich keinen Betroffenen gab, der während der Überwachung mitgekriegt habe, das überwacht wurde. An welchem Punkt ist den Leuten eigentlich aufgefallen, dass sie möglicherweise einen Staatstrojaner auf der Festplatte haben oder hatten?
Na ja, die Fälle, die wir kennen, da war es relativ simpel. Man kriegt die Akten, und dann wird das Verfahren eröffnet und man findet Screenshots.
Das ist also während der Kriegsverhandlung schon?
Nein, nein, damit das Verfahren eröffnet ist, man muss ja nicht schon vor Gericht stehen, damit eben andere Einsichten die Akten nehmen können. Das kann natürlich früher sein. Also man entdeckt einfach Dinge, die man eigentlich so nicht haben könnte. Es gibt noch andere Wege, wie man an eine Form von Screenshots kommt. Also technisch gibt es auch andere Wege. Aber hier hatte der Anwalt, der auch noch, also der Strafverteidiger, der auch noch recht jung war, und jetzt sozusagen nicht technikfern, aber schon eine gewisse Peilung hat von Technik, auch gleich ein Verdacht. Also ich denke, ein guter Strafverteidiger würde das wahrscheinlich sehr schnell überblicken.
Okay, aber das ist der Punkt, dass man schon die Ergebnisse vorlegt und weiß dann, okay, da war möglicherweise irgendwas.
Naja, letztlich, man könnte natürlich auch verbergen. Wenn man es ja in die Akten nicht aufnehmen würde, würde man es nicht unbedingt erfahren. Die Maßnahme bleibt ja heimlich. Also wenn man jetzt nicht einen Trojaner selber entdeckt und in den Akten nichts findet, kann man es natürlich letztlich auch nicht wissen. Also, natürlich außer für den Trojaner, den wir jetzt haben, der wird ja von dem Virus genauer erkannt.
Ich muss auch dazu sagen, dass in einem Verfahren zumindest da auch schon Screenshots aufgetaucht sind, die vor dem richterlichen Beschluss oder der Bestätigung, dass das durchgeführt werden darf, erstellt wurden. Da vielleicht nochmal ein paar Worte zum Richtervorbehalt. Das ist eine Maßnahme, wo eben vorher ein Richter sagen muss, ja, das darf durchgeführt werden. Und ja, da dürfte eigentlich vorher das schon gar nicht eingesetzt wurden. Das wurde da so leger im Nachhinein mal eben als Legitimierung. Eigentlich wurden da Dinge vor Gericht eingebracht, wo eben noch nicht mal ein Richter vorher gesagt hat, das ist okay.
Das ist so wie in der amerikanischen Polizeiseite. Der Polizist tritt die Tür ein und sagt, Hausversuchungsbefehl besorgen wir uns morgen.
Nein, also sowas gibt es im deutschen Recht auch offiziell. Den nennt man Gefahr im Verzug. Also es gibt natürlich Sachen, da kann man diese Richtergenehmigung im Nachhinein einholen, wenn man eben konkreten, ja, fährwiegenden Gefahren entgegenwirken will. Wenn man jetzt an die Quellentickerühe oder an eine Online-Durchsuchung denkt, das ist ja nichts, was sofort passieren kann, sondern hat ja einen gewissen Vorlauf. Man muss ja erstmal ausspionieren, was ist das für ein Rechner? In der Regel muss man auch, es ist ja eine Maßnahme, die ganz am Ende passiert. Da hat man ja schon sowieso alle E-Mails, alle Internetüberwachung, da hat man schon Festnetzelefon, da hat man alle Handyschen abgehört und muss natürlich auch nur einige wissen über denjenigen, den man dort abhört. Insofern ist es ja nicht unbedingt eine Sofortmaßnahme. Aber schon verpflichtend mit diesem Richtervorbehalt. Und da ist natürlich uns auch die Frage, gerade wenn man da technisch drauf guckt, wie kann der eigentlich wissen...
Wie kann ein Richter das beurteilen? Wie kann ein Richter sagen, okay, das ist eine Maßnahme, und dann sage ich ja, das ist eine Maßnahme, und dann sage ich nein. Und das war für mich so das, wo ich am meisten in den letzten Wochen gelernt habe, wie sowas abläuft von den Prozessen her. Die gucken sich das nicht groß an, weil der Aufwand, sowas abzulehnen, wesentlich höher ist, und da macht man sich deutlich unbeliebter, als wenn man sowas durchwinkt. Also ein Richter hat wesentlich weniger Aufwand, damit da überall sein Okay drunter zu setzen, weil die Staatsanwaltschaft, die wird schon nur Dinge einreichen, die jetzt irgendwie Hand und Fuß haben. Man kennt sich da ja auch, und das ist ja dann ein Umgang, der vertrauter ist. Und das ist für die Ungleich aufwendiger, sowas abzulehnen, und das macht man sich natürlich auch sehr unbeliebt.
Der Richter kann unterschreiben und sagen, ja, das findet statt, und wenn er nein sagt, muss er es begründen?
Genau.
Also es ist schon tatsächlich ein strukturelles Problem. Und die Forderung danach, das umzudrehen, die ist sehr alt, zu sagen, also wenn der Richter ablehnt, dann kann er es einfach durchwinken, und wenn er es annimmt, dann muss er es begründen. Aber hier gibt es natürlich Widerstände, die auch politischer Natur sind, die sehr verständlich sind. Bei uns ist es ja dann eine Sache, die letztlich in den Ländern zu finanzieren wäre. Denn man bräuchte dafür mehr Richter. Man muss sich überlegen, wie viele Hundert am Tag von verschiedenen Anordnungen Richter, Ermittlungsrichter unterschreiben. Und natürlich müsste man für mehr Leute sorgen, wenn die sich mehr Zeit nehmen und mehr prüfen.
Das würde unterstrich bedeuten, dass sie sich das dann auch wirklich angucken müssen.
Und was sollen sie sich hier eigentlich angucken? Die Produktpräsentation von Digitas? Also das ist ja auch nochmal ein ganz faktisches Problem. Soll man ernsthaft erwarten, dass sich ein Ermittlungsrichter mit dem Quellenkod ausbaut?
Das heißt jetzt nicht, sondern ich dachte sagen, wenn, dann gibt es dieses Instrument. Irgendwie eine Richter muss nur über den Einsatz entscheiden.
Ja, aber er muss schon vertrauen, dass die Firma oder auch letztlich die Firma, die es herstellt oder die es im Auftrag herstellt, ihm da die Wahrheit sagt. Muss man schon voraussetzen können und zum Beispiel auch keine schlimmen Fehler einbaut. Das kann er ja nicht wissen. Letztlich, wenn er es nur hört, da gibt es ein Produkt, das hat diese und jene Funktionalitäten. Also da hat er ja faktisch wenig Möglichkeiten. Dass natürlich der Ermittlungsrichter im Fall von dem Landshut, also sozusagen unser erster Trojaner, nicht von vornherein kritisch war, ist natürlich schon zu hinterfragen. Denn hier war ja eine Software im Einsatz, die eben nicht nur die Skype abhören konnte, sondern eben auch die Bildschirmfotos gemacht hat. Das wurde ja erst im Nachhinein für rechtswidrig erklärt. Da muss man sich schon fragen, wo war denn da eigentlich die rechtliche Vorprüfung?
Jetzt in der Diskussion kommt ja immer wieder auch die Forderung auf. Das klingt dann immer so, als ob das die Lösung wäre. Na ja, in Zukunft wird der Staatstrojaner einfach von offiziellen Stellen dann programmiert. Dann kann er richtig auch darauf vertrauen.
Mit den Leuten von Digitas und Abwehr?
Weiß ich nicht, wer das dann machen soll, aber es ist auch Quatsch, oder?
Es ist ein Vorschlag, den man natürlich mal debattieren kann. Aber letztlich ist es nur dann ein Vorschlag, wenn man die Probleme, die sich jenseits davon stellen, auch mitlöst. Wenn man meint, man hat genug Know-how, dann muss man natürlich in Erwägung ziehen. Aber da gibt es eine Behörde, die viel Know-how darin hat. Das ist das Bundesamt für Sicherheiten der Informationstechnik. Und ich würde sehr hoffen, dass die dafür nicht zum Einsatz kommt. Eine Behörde, die sehr viel über Spionagestoftware und Mailware weiß und auch wie man seine Rechner dagegen nutzt, die gibt es damit, mit diesem BSI. Aber die wäre natürlich sehr schlecht beraten, wenn sie jetzt den Spagat versucht, auf einer Seite selber die Spionagestoftware zu bauen, aber auf der anderen Seite die Bürger und Firmen beraten, wie sie sich vor dieser Spionagestoftware schützen.
Vor dieser dann vielleicht nichts, aber vor allen anderen.
Ja, schon, aber das ist von der Glaubwürdigkeit her sehr schwierig, da zu stehen.
Gut, jetzt können wir natürlich sagen, wir bilden das urische Kompetenzzentrum. Anderen nennen sie ja die Überwachungszentrale oder so. Keine Ahnung, da muss man sich schon mal fragen, wen stellen sie da ein. Aber tendenziell hätte ich keine Einwendung, wenn der Staat so etwas entwickelt. Aber dennoch müssen alle Probleme gelöst werden. Und nicht nur die Frage, ob die Firma dann ein Geschäftsgeheimnis haben darf und den Quellcode nicht ausrückt.
Aber habe ich zu verpasst, war nicht irgendwann mitten in der Sendung die Forderung, es soll gar keinen Staat zu ernergeben?
Na ja, aus meiner Sicht wäre das eine gute Forderung. Also ich denke, man sollte... Ja, für alle Überwachungsmaßnahmen muss man sich immer überlegen, ist es verhältnismäßig und zwar im engeren oder weiteren Sinne. Das heißt, gibt es mildere Mittel, die man einsetzen kann? Und ein milderes Mittel als die Infiltration eines Rechners ist das Abhören beim Anbieter. Warum man diesen Weg dann nicht auch beschreiten will, das stellt sich mir schon als Frage. Nur, weil was technisch geht. Genen tut noch viel mehr.
Aber dann hätte man dieses Problem spätestens dann wieder, wenn tatsächlich gute Verschlüsselung für audio funktioniert.
Möchtest du die Verschlüsselung der Besitz zu sagen, Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die sicher sind?
Nein, aber dann geht es irgendwann nicht mehr, dass man beim Anbieter abhören kann.
Dann hätte man diese Diskussion wieder.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du ein Gerät einsetzt, was eine ordentliche Verschlüsselung hat, dann setzt du auch ein Gerät ein, was gegen so etwas wie eine Trojaner Installation gesichert ist. Das ist ja nicht so, als könnte man so Geräte nicht bauen, als würden so Geräte nicht gebaut und als würden so Geräte nicht eingesetzt. Also letztendlich ist die Lücke oder der Horizont, in dem so eine Software eingesetzt werden kann, so unendlich klein, wenn man es wirklich rechtlich konform macht. Und die anderen Mittel, die man da zur Verfügung hat, so mannigfaltig vorhanden, als dass sich das nicht, allein auch für die Ausgabe mehrere Millionen auf so ein Produkt zu werfen, das überhaupt nicht in einer Relation steht zu den Möglichkeiten, die man sonst noch ausschöpfen könnte.
Also es ist natürlich eine Debatte, die wir in Zukunft immer haben werden. Das ist, glaube ich, keine Sache, die wir nur in diesem Monat debattieren oder in diesem Jahr. Denn die Problematik wird sich stellen. Wir brauchen für eine ordentlich funktionierende IT heutzutage, egal ob privat oder wirtschaftlich, brauchen wir eine funktionierende Kopptographie. Einfach schlicht treiben sich genug normale Kriminelle rum, die irgendwie Spionage-Software benutzen. Und da muss man Lösungen finden, das sehe ich schon.
Also allein Wirtschaftsspionage, das ist ja gerade in Deutschland wichtig, wo wir von Innovationen abhängig sind, dass Firmen forschen, dass Firmen wirklich Geheimnisse haben und diese auch geschäftlich nutzen.
Wenn man dann immer die Argumentation hört, der Staat muss da irgendwie auf Augenhöhe agieren, ich finde halt, dass er das nicht muss. Denn er ist eben kein Krimineller, sondern er ist erstmal ein Staat, der sich an Regeln hält. Und ob zu den Regeln gehören muss, in die quasi Gehirne von Menschen einzudringen, nur weil sie jetzt die Möglichkeit haben, das wird sie so denken, aufzuschreiben, auch wenn den Rechner nie verlässt. Ich finde, das ist eine grundsätzliche Frage, die auch wirklich aus meiner Sicht eine Wertedebatte ist, inwieweit wir dazulassen wollen. Und ich neige da nicht dazu, das sofort entscheiden zu wollen für alle Zukunft, aber schon gar nicht immer nur dem Wünschen und Wollen von der Mittler zu folgen.
Jetzt ist die Sendung bald zu Ende. Wir haben den Trojaner ausführlich auseinandergenommen. Über Twitter kam gerade noch die Frage rein, ob ihr eine Prognose habt, ob und wann der Herr Friedrich zurücktreten wird?
Die muss ich lieber machen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob der Skandal so lange auch über Vorgaben aus Karlsruhe hinweg gesehen zu haben und das ja eigentlich auch in Zukunft fortführen zu wollen. Das ist ja eine Sache, die er würde fortführen. Da gibt es ja nicht mal so einen Moment Stillstand und Nachdenken. Ich weiß nicht, ob das genügen wird.
Da fehlt auch immer die Selbsterkenntnis, also wirklich die festzustellen, dass man da Unrecht getan hat, dass man sich gegen ein Grundgesetz offen ausgesprochen hat. Die Scham fehlt da.
Politische Scham, ja. Aber nicht nur bei Herrn Friedrichs, sondern bei der gesamten politischen Kaste, möchte ich es mal nennen.
Nein, ich würde keine generelle Politikerbeschimpfung loslassen.
Der Innenminister, wenn er zurücktritt, das könnte er entweder machen, weil er selber sagt, okay, das war schlimm, ich muss zurücktreten, oder er könnte das machen, wenn genug Druck im Umfeld entsteht. Und zumindest dieses Umfeld hat nicht genug Scham, um diesen Druck zu erzeugen.
Oder eben eine offensichtliche Lüge. Manche brauchen länger bei Gutenberg, wenn sie offensichtliche Lügen geben, dann zurücktreten, aber in der Regel ist eine offensichtliche Lüge auch nochmal ein Grund. Das wäre eine Möglichkeit. Aber am liebsten hätte man natürlich einen Anständigen.
Ein Anständigen Politiker meinste?
Ich bin nicht so ein Freund von allgemeiner Politikerstellte. Man sollte schon den Einzelfall betrachten. So wie bei Hackern auch.
Beurteile einen Politiker nie nach dem, was er sagt, sondern nach seinem Jurist.
Oder wie er abstimmt.
Okay, also vielen Dank fürs hier sein, fürs Auseinander in den Straatstrojanern. Constanze Kurz und Libla vom Chaos Computer Club in der Folge 73 des Chaosradios über besagten Staatstrojaner. Gibt es sonst noch Dinge vom CCC, die man wissen sollte, die jetzt anstehen?
Ja, wir haben bald wieder ein Kongress.
Nein!
Ja, zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr. Nein! Es geht jetzt gerade so los, dass das Programm festgezogt wird. Und wir können jetzt schon versprechen, dass es ein sehr spannendes Programm wird.
Gibt es Programme? Wo wird es stattfinden?
Wir sind wie immer am Alex, vier Tage lang im BCC, also im Berliner Kongresszentrum. Und wir freuen uns natürlich, wenn bald die Ticket…
Wollte gerade sagen, wann jetzt los? Weiß man schon, wann es losgeht?
Nein, steht noch nicht ganz fest, aber es wird wieder einen Vorverkauf geben. Denn wir wollen natürlich nicht, dass da jemand in der Kälte anstehen muss. Wir versuchen es doch so zu organisieren, dass es da keinen Stress gibt.
Alles klar. Wir werden mal schauen, ob das funktioniert. Im nächsten Monat gibt es dann nochmal ein Chaosradio, das letzte für dieses Jahr.
Wir haben doch schon eine Themenidee, wir verraten aber noch nichts.
Geheimnisvoll, einen ganzen Monat vorher sogar schon. Wie konnte das passieren? Wir werden mal gucken, ob das klappt. Mir bleibt dann in diesem Fall nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network, Biax, XO2000.